bonjour à tous suite ce matin du projet
de loi de finances pour 2011 mercredi
dernier les sénateurs ont adopté la
première partie du budget celle des
recettes placées sous le signe de la
crise et des économies depuis les
sénateurs examinent les crédits mission
par mission et ils débattent ce matin du
budget de la justice ce budget tr
puisqu'il est en hausse de 4,15 % par
rapport à celui de 2010 il prévoit la
création de 550 emplois et ce budget
devrait dépasser les 7 milliards d'euros
néanmoins il reste l'un des plus faibles
d'Europe il met l'accent sur trois
points la modernisation des juridictions
l'ouverture de nouvelles places en
prison et la construction de nouveaux
établissements pénitentiaires et sur
l'accès au droit avec la réforme de la
garde à vue à noter le contexte sensible
dans lequel s'insère ce budget puisque
la semaine dernière le nouveau garde des
saau Michel mertier a dû faire face à la
grogne des gardiens de prison qui
demande plus de moyens et plus
d'effectifs tout de suite donc direction
l'hémicycle pour la suite du projet de
loi de finances pour
2011 l'ordre du jour appelle la suite de
la discussion des articles de la seconde
partie du projet de loi de finances pour
2011 adopté par l'Assemblée nationale le
Sénat va examiner les crédits de la
mission justice et les articles 75 et 75
bis
la parole est à Monsieur Roland d
rapporteur spécial de la commission des
finances madame la
présidente monsieur le ministre monsieur
le garde des saau c'est pour moi une
joie de retrouver ici en tant qu'ancien
sénateur et surtout dans ses fonctions
de garde des saut qui Honor le Sénat par
votre intermédiaire mes chers collègues
la mission justice est dotée pour 2011
de 7,1 milliards d'euros de crédit de
paiement soit une augmentation de 4,1 %.
sur la période
2011-2013 ces moyens continueront de
progresser de 3,3 %. ce qui traduit bien
la priorité accord à la justice depuis
la loi d'orientation et de programmation
de
2002 le programme justice judiciaire
compte
2,959 milliards d'euros en crédit de
paiement soit une hausse de 4,4
%. les créations nettes d'emploi se
montent à 127 équivalent en plein pour
un plafond d'emploi fixé à
3118 équivalent temp plein les efforts
afin d'accroître les effectifs de
magistrat ne sont ependant de sens que
s'il s'accompagne d'un effort encore
plus important en faveur des greffiers
or le ratio entre le nombre de greffiers
et celui de magistrat n'est encore
actuellement que de
0,86 l'objectif doit être de l'amener
progressivement à un niveau proche de 1
pour 1 mais je constate que tout ceci
progresse dans le bon
sens pour 2011 l'enveloppe alloué au
titre des frais de justice s'élève à
159,4 million d'euros les charges
restantes à payer devraient toutefois
représenter près de 100 millions d'euros
à la fin de l'exercice budgétaire 2010
ce montant correspond à environ 2 mois
d'activité des juridictions il apparaît
donc que la sous-budgétisation constatée
en 2009 en 2010 se poursuit en
2011 c'est la raison pour laquelle la
commission des finances m'a demandé de
vous présenter un amendement sur les
crédits de cette mission
un autre enjeu pour l'institution
judiciaire réside dans la mise en œuvre
de la réforme de la carte judiciaire à
cet égard il convient de se féliciter
que cette réforme avance sans que son
coût ne dérape celui-ci toujours estimé
à 427 millions d'euros sur 5
ans une dernière question se pose
concernant la performance monsieur le
ministre de la justice judiciaire
c'est celle de l'exécution des peines
monsieur le gardess pouvez-vous nous
éclairer sur ce point et de nous donner
votre appréciation sur
l'effectivité des décisions
pénales en 2011 les efforts en faveur du
programme administration pénancière se
poursuivront ce programme verra ainsi
ses autorisation d'engagement progressé
de 6,8 % et ses crédits de paiement de
4,5 il enregistraa par ailleurs un gain
net de 413 emplois supplémentaires pour
un plafond d'emploi de
34857 équivalent en plein cette
augmentation des crédits permettra
notamment de répondre aux besoins en
personnel liés à l'ouverture de
nouvelles places en détention au cours
de
l'exercice le nombre de création net de
plac en détention en 201 se montrera en
effet à
1139 les efforts d'investissement
réalisés au cours de ces derniers
exercices commen à porter leur fruit
depuis
2008 le grave écueil de la surpopulation
carcérale n'est cependant pas encore
totalement surmonté la préoccupation
majeure consiste dans les établissements
dans la densité est supérieur à 200
%. s'agissant de la question récurrente
des transférements de détenus une
décision importante est
intervenue à compté du 1er janvier 2
la responsabilité de ces transférements
entre les cellules et les palais de
justice ainsi que des missions d'escorte
et de garde des détenus hospitalisés
dans les unités hospitalières sécurisées
interrégionales sera transféré au
ministère de la Justice seul les détenus
particulièrement signalés entre
guillemets continueront de relever de la
police et de la gendarmerie cette mesure
va s'accompagner d'un transfert de 800
équip valant temps plein en faveur de
l'administration pénitentiaire à cet
égard monsieur le garde d saau la
commission des finances souhaiterait
connaître les deux régions qui devent
être pilotes sur cette expérimentation
dès le début de 2011 enfin la prise en
charge des cas de psychiatrie en milieu
carcéral constitue un sujet de
préoccupation constant or les moyens
dédiés à cette mission sont insuffisants
la pénurie de psychiatre est d'autant
plus préjudiciable qu'environ 20 à 25 %
et c'est un minimum des détenus
souffrent de troubles psychiatriqu c'est
suation doit trouver des solution dans
les années à venir que pouvez-vous nous
dire à ce
sujet depuis 2009 le programme
protection judiciaire de la jeunesse
privilégie la prise en charge des
mineurs délinquants l'année 2011
représente une année charnière pour la
PGJ qui a accompli d'importants efforts
de rationalisation en effet conçu sur 4
ans son projet stratégique national va
toucher à son terme le programme
comporte
757,9 million d'euros en crédit de
paiement soit une diminution de 2,1 %.
il enregistrera la perte de 1440
équivalent temp plein son plafond
d'emploi baissant à 8501 équivalent temp
plein toutefois il faut souligner que
ces suppressions de postes ne concernent
que les fonctions support et pas les
éducations
mais j'insiste sur le fait que je pense
qu'on a atteint le plancher et qu'il
faut pas déstabiliser l'institution qui
est fort bien
gérée au total l'action de la PGJ
débouche sur un résultat encourageant 70
% des jeunes pris en charge au pénal n'
ni récidivé ni réitéré ni fait l'objet
de nouvell poursuites dans l'année dans
l'année qui a suivi la clôture de la
mesure les moyens du programme Accès au
droit de la justice augmentent 12,4 % en
crédit de paiement en atteignant
331 millions d'euros en particulier
l'aide juridictionnelle voit sa dotation
passé de
274 à
312,3 millions d'euros en 2011 cette ha
significative et cependant trompeuse
elle s'applique essentiellement par le
fait que l'année prochaine les crédits
devront également couvrir
l'assuétissement des rétributions
versées aux avocats et aux avoués à un
taux de TVA de 196 contre 5 5
antérieurement la commission des
finances se félicite toutefois que le
projet de loi de finan pour 2011
instaore un ticket modérateur de
8,84 € à la charge du bénéficiaire de
l'aide juridictionnelle désormais nous
l'espérons mieux
responsabilisé par ailleurs la réforme à
venir de la garde à vue constituera n'en
pas douter un défi majeur à relever en
2011 au regard du budget cons cré à
cette aide la commission des finances y
sera parculrement attentive ce genre de
réforme impliquant les moyens
adéquats le programme conduite et
pilotage de la politique de la justice
comporte 267 million d'euros de crédit
de paiement en progression de 7,3 % par
rapport à 2010 cette hausse
significative des crédits consacrés à
l'administration centrale et au projet
informatique pourrait surprendre elle
doit cependant être relativisée dans la
mesure où elle résulte pour une grande
part de changement de périmètre l'un des
enjeux pour 2011 résidera dans la
réussite du regroupement sur un site
unique de l'ensemble des directions de
l'administration centrale ce
déménagement devant permettre de dégager
des économies de loyer en conclusion et
sous la réserve de l'amendement que je
vous présenterai dans quelques minutes
dont nous discuterons la commission des
finances propose au Sénat l'adoption des
crédits proposés par pour la mission
justice et pour chacun de ces programmes
je vous remercie de votre attention
merci monsieur le rapporteur spécial
monsieur la parole est à Monsieur
Jean-René leerve rapporteur pour avis de
la commission des
lois
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre de la Justice garde des saut
mes chers collègues le projet de loit de
finance pour 2011 prévoit une
progression de 4 et5i % des crédits du
programme administration pénitentiaire
au sein de la mission justice dont la
dotation augmente globalement de 4,1 %.
dans un contexte budgétaire
particulièrement difficile ces chiffres
marquent un incontestable effort
accompli en faveur de la
effort qui s'inscrit dans la durée le
budget de la justice est ainsi passé de
2001 à 2011 de 4,3 à 7,128 milliards
d'euros soit une augmentation de 65 %.
le programme administration
pénitentiaire représente 39 % de
l'émission justice soit une dotation en
crédit de paiement de 2,8 milliards
tandis que les autorisations
d'engagement augmentent de 6,7 % à 3,2
ard
d'euros le plafond d'autorisation
d'emploi s'élève à
34857 équivalent temps plein travailler
contre 33860 en 2010 soit 997 ETPT
supplémentaires en 1 an et 1837 en 2 ans
au titre de ce simple constat votre
commission des Lois a donné un avis
favorable à l'adoption des crédits du
programme pénitentiaire de la mission
justice inscrit dans le projet de loi de
finance pour 2011 je souhaite cependant
exprimer aussi un certain nombre
d'inquiétude et interroger le
gouvernement le garde des saau sur
certains aspects de la politique
pénitentiaire qui n'emportent pas
d'emblé notre
adhésion notre principale interrogation
porte sur le risque d'une déconnexion
entre les exercices budgétaires
successifs et les exigences de
l'application de la loi pénitentiaire du
24 novembre
2009 nous n'observons pas en particulier
de R équilibrage des recrutements en
faveur des services pénitentiaires
d'insertion et de probation pourtant
indispensable à la réussite de la
politique d'aménagement de peine qui est
au cœur de la loi
pénitentiaire ainsi l'augmentation du
plafond d'emploi concerne
essentiellement les personnels de
surveillance et correspond
principalement à la création des emplois
permettant de faire face à l'ouverture
des nouveaux établissements prévus en
2011 dans le cadre du programme Perben
de 13200 places
en outre une réorientation dès l'an
prochain en faveur des SPIP apparaît
difficilement conciliable avec l'annonce
de création de 5000 places
supplémentaires au titre d'un nouveau
programme immobilier autant notre
commission des lois est totalement
favorable monsieur le ministre au
remplacement des places obsolètes par
des places conformes au respect de la
dignité des personnes détenues autant
elle estime nécessaire d'en rester au
moins à moyen terme à un objectif de
63000 places correspondant à un ratio
d'incarcération de 100 pour 100000
habitants qui se situe dans une
honorable moyenne européenne je rappelle
que selon l'étude d'impact accompagnant
la loi pénitentiaire l'augmentation du
nombre des aménagements de peine
exigeait la création de 1000 postes de
conseillers d'insertion et de probation
les créations successives de TPT au
titre des métiers de l'insertion 148
dans la loi de finance 2010 et 114 dans
la loi de financeces 2011 à supposer
qu'il se concrétise demeure très modeste
seconde inquiétude le projet annuel de
performance n'est guère adapté aux
grandes orientations de la loi
pénitentiaire et que l'idée est un peu
la même bien des cibles apparaissent
en-dessà des objectifs souhaitables
ainsi pour le taux de détenu bénéficiant
d'une activité rémunérée la cible pour
2011 37,4 % marque une infime
augmentation par rapport au résultat
2009 35,7 %. est-elle susceptible de
mobiliser l'administration pénitentiaire
autour de l'ardente obligation de
développer des activités afin de
répondre à l'obligation inscrite dans la
loi il est permis d'en douter de même
est-il vraiment pertinent de calculer
l'indicateur concernant l'amélioration
de l'accès au soins sur la base du
nombre d'établissements ayant actualisé
leur protocole d'accord avec les
services de soins mesure présentant un
caractère purement administratif le
nombre d'emplois de médecins effectif
pourvu ou encore celui des consultations
donnerait des éléments d'information
plus utiles enfin les éléments de
présentation actuelles présentent des
lacune évidente au regard de certaines
orientations de la loi pénitentiaire
ainsi s'il est indispensable de mesurer
le taux d'incident danst les personnel
sont victimes la sécurité des
établissements doit aussi s'apprécier à
travers les violences commises en
détention sur les personnes
détenu 3è élément d'inquiétude a trait à
la baisse des moyens de fonction
destiné aux établissements en gestion
publique dont les conséquences pourrai
être très dommageables sur la
maintenance des infrastructures que l'on
songe par exemple au coût de la
réhabilitation de flur Merogis cette
baisse s'explique en partie par
l'augmentation des crédits consacré à la
gestion déléguée en raison de la montée
en charge des marchés nous attirons
votre attention monsieur le ministre sur
le risque d'une d'un parc à deux
vitesses dans l'avenir dernier point le
problème de l'encédulement indiv
vous savez combien le Sénat s'y était
montré attaché je constate avec
satisfaction des progrès importants liés
à la fois à l'augmentation du nombre des
places avec la réalisation du programme
Perben et la diminution du nombre de
personnes détenues savez-vous mes chers
collègues qu'entre le 1er octobre 2009
et le 1er octobre 2010 nous avons fait
baisser de moitié le nombre des
établissements pénitentiaires qui
connaissent une densité d'occupation
supérieure à 150 % ce qui est tout à
fait remarquable mais monsieur le
ministre nous sommes som parfois surpris
de voir la justification d'établissement
que l'administration pénitentiaire
souhaite fermer
être celle de l'impossibilité d'arriver
à un taux de 95 à 100 % de
d'encellulement individuel ce n'est pas
ce que le Sénat avait réclamé le Sénat
n'est pas un hayatolla de l'enseignement
individuel la loi Perben lorsqu'elle a
été mise en place et qu'elle a prévu les
13200 places et bien elle prévoyait 30 %
de cellules collectives sur ce point
monsieur ministre nous comptons sur
votre modération pour que le principe de
l'enseignement individuel soit respecté
avec les diverses exceptions qui sont
prévues par la loi et qui pourrait
justifier effectivement pour les maisons
d'arrêt 30 % de cellules collectives
dans un principe d' cellulement
individuel je vous remercie merci mon
chers collègue la parole est à Monsieur
Yve desreg rapporteur pour avis de la
commission des
lois
madame la présidente monsieur le garde
DESS saau mais mes chers collègues
évoquer le budget de la justice cette
année c'est pour moi être partagé entre
deux approche relativement divergente
d'une part il faut se féliciter que les
crédits des programmes justice
judiciaire et accès au droit soi en
progression alors que notre pays
s'engage dans un effort considérable de
réduction de ses dépenses publiques mais
d'autre part force de constater que les
magistrats et les fonctionnaires doivent
bien souvent faire face à une pénurie de
moyen qui oblige les chefs de cours à
renoncé à certaines dépenses de
fonctionnement pour assurer par exemple
le paiement des frais de justice une
pénurie qui semble par ailleurs réduire
les dialogues de gestion à une simple
validation des propositions de
l'administration centrale par les chefs
de cours si ce qui me conduit à ma
première observation sur ce budget 2011
il s'agit de l'application de la de la
LOLF à la justice la logique de
performance induite par la LOLF a sans
doute permis d'accompagner un mouvement
de rationalisation du travail des
juridictions toutefois l'approche
statistique n'offre qu'une vue
schématique et même parfois déformé de
l'activité judiciaire ainsi pour prendre
cet exemple l'indicateur relatif au
nombre d'affaires pénales traité par les
magistrats du siège agrège les jugements
correctionnels les ordonnances pénales
les compositions pénales les compartions
sur reconnaissance préalable de
culpabilité ce qui revient à agréger
sans distinction des affaires qui
nécessitent pourtant un investissement
et un temps passé sensiblement différent
j'en viiens donc à ma première question
monsieur le garde des saut les nouvelles
implications informatique tel le fameux
Cassiopé permettront-elles un jour
d'affiner ces indicateurs de rendre une
vision plus fine et plus juste de
l'activité judiciaire et par voie de
conséquence de mieux adapter ses moyens
à la réalité des besoins des
juridictions je voudrais maintenant
évoquer l'achèvement en 2011 de la
réforme de la carte judiciaire la
nouvelle carte sera normalement en place
le 1er janvier prochain et on aura donc
865 juridictions judiciaaires contre
1193 précédemment les magistrats et les
fonctionnaires de la justice jugent
globalement satisfaisante la prise en
compte de la situation des personnels
dans le cadre de la mise en œuvre de
cette réforme l'accompagnement
immobilier lui paraît semble-t-il plus
problématique et l'évaluation de son
coût suscite des interrogations en effet
la mise en œuvre de cette réforme se
traduit par la réalisation de plus de
400 opérations immobilières dont une
centaine d'opérations à titre provisoire
et compte tenu du coûte ce volet
immobilier les résultats en terme
d'économie budgétaire de la mise en
place d'une nouvelle carte judiciaire ne
pourront donc être observés qu'à long
terme par ailleurs et je voudrais dire
un mot là-dessus le développement des
maisons de la justice et du droit
notamment l'emjd nouvelle génération
constitue j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire
les années précédentes le complément
indispensable de la réforme de la carte
judiciaire afin de maintenir un accès
facile à la justice sur l'ensemble du
territoire et en particulier pour les
populations les plus fragiles qui sont
aussi souvent il faut le dire les
justiçables que l'on retrouve le plus
devant les tribunaux d'instance or force
de constater qu'un certain nombre de
CMJD ne peuvent fonctionner correctement
car dans l'ensemble elle fonctionne pas
trop mal qu'en raison de l'appoint au
personnel apporté par les C colctivité
locale faute pour la juridiction de
rattachement d'avoir les moyens d'y
déléguer un greffier donc je soulève
cette question j'en viens maintenant à
l'augmentation des frais de justice
après avoir diminué en 2006 de 22,1 %
c'était l'heureux surprise de la mise en
application de la LOLF dans le domaine
de de la justice les dépenses afférentes
au frais de justice sont à nouveau en
progression depuis 2007 et la Haus a
même atteint 7,7 % l'an dernier il
paraît très inquiétant que
l'insuffisance des crédits alloués au
frais de justice conduise certaines
juridictions à réduire leur frais de
fonctionnement pour pouvoir honorer ces
factures ce sont alors des crédits qui
auraient dû être consacrés à un emploi
de vacataire ou d'assistant de justice
voire de juges de proximité qui sont en
fait utilisés à partir de de des 2/3 de
l'année pour le paiement des frais de
justice la plupart des juridictions
arrêtent d'ailleurs purement et
simplement de régler des frais de
justice dès octobre ou novembre et dès
le début de l'année il faudra
effectivement renflouer les les crédits
des économies semblent pouvoir être
encore réalisé notamment par de nouveaux
Parchet publics en matière d'analyse
génétique et par la mise en place de la
plateforme nationale d'interception
judiciaire j'aimerais monsieur le
ministre que vous pouviez que vous
puissiez nous dire si ce projet doit
bien aboutir en 2011 et quelles
économies budgétaires devraient en
résulter en ce qui concerne les
effectifs la commission des lois est
préoccupé par l'absence de gestion
prévisionnelle le budget 2011 met un
terme au mouvement d'augmentation du
nombre de magistrats dont on peut
convenir qu'il a atteint un niveau
satisfaisant il faut sans doute
aujourd'hui mettre l'accent sur
l'augmentation des postes de greffiers
et de fonctionnaires à cet égard le
projet de loi de finance prévoit la
création de 389 et équivalent en plein
de greffier mais il prévoit aussi la
suppression de 76 ETP de magistrats et
de 196 ETP de fonctionnaires de
catégorie C et ce mouvement inquiète la
commission des lois tout d'abord la
politique de transformation d'emploi de
secrétaire administratif en emploi de
greffier conduit à un déficit dans la
première catégorie et certains
magistrats sont ainsi amenés à consacrer
une partie de leur temps à des tâches
d'exécution au détriment de leur
fonction première ensuite l'absence de
gestion prévisionnelle des effectifs
laisse crainreune évaporation des
progrès accomplis ces dernières années
en effet nous savons que le nombre de
départs à la retraite de magistrat doit
croître de façon continue dans les
prochaines années pour atteindre de
l'ordre de 300 départs par an à compter
de 2016-20 17 c'est demain or le nombre
de places offertes aux trois concours de
l'École nationale de la magistrature est
stabilisé depuis 3 ans à 105 et le
nombre de recrutements parallèle diminue
la mise en place d'une gestion
prévisionnelle des effectifs de
magistrats et de fonctionnaires des
services judiciaires paraît donc
essentiel pour assurer le succès de la
politique de rattrapage des moyens de la
justice et faire en sorte qu'elle ne
soit pas transitoire à cet égard
l'évaluation des gains attendus des
réformes en cours en terme d'emploi
paraît optimiste qu'il s'agit de la
carte judiciaire ou des nouvelles
applications informatiques de même il
semble très ambitieux d'escomter que 500
magistrats et 500 560 fonctionnaires
puissent constituer la réserve
judiciaire prévue par l'article 75 B du
projet de loi finance quand on sait
notamment que 71 magistrat seulement
sont actuellement maintenus en activité
en surnombre au-delà de leur âge de
départ en retraite je n'évoquerai l'
juridictionnelle que pour indiquer que
la dotation prévue sera insuffisante la
réforme de la garde à vue va nécessiter
un renforcement de de ces crédits je ne
suis pas sûr que le paiement direct du
troit de pldoirie par chaque justiciable
soit à la hauteur du du problème donc
monsieur le ministre nous vous attendons
aussi nous attendons vos vos
informations sur ce point enfin enfin je
termine madame la Présidente je souhaite
évoquer la place du Conseil supérieur de
la magistrature dans l'architecture de
la mission justice les crédits alloués
au CSM sont en augmentation il prend
désormais en charge dépense de
fonctionnement qui était auparavant
assumé par la présidence de la
République et le nombre de ces membres
passe de 16 à 22 dans quelques semaine
pouvez-vous nous indiquer monsieur le
ministre s'il est locaux parce que la
question se pose affecté au CSM vont lui
permettre d'accueillir ces ces 22
membres et de fonctionner correctement
en particulier pour l'examen des
demandes des justiciables qui pourront
le saisir de fait susceptible de mettre
en cause la responsabilité disciplinaire
des magistrats sur la question de la
place du CMM du CSM nous allons discuter
dans quelques instants nous proposons la
commission des lois propose que dans
l'architecture budgétaire un programme
spécifique soit réservé au CSM comme
nous le demandons depuis des années et
je dois dire que c'est une proposition
qui fait l'unanimité des membres de la
commission des lois sous le bénéfice de
l'ensemble de ces observations la
commission des lois a donné un avis
favorable à l'adoption des crédits
alloué au programme justice judiciaire
et accès au droit et à la justice merci
la parole est à Monsieur Nicolas Alfons
rapporteur pour avis de la commission
des
lois monsieur le
ministre chers collègues pour la 3e
année consécutive le programme 182 des
crédits alloués à la PGJ diminue
- 2 % en moyenne après une baisse de - 2
% 2009 de 1 % 2010 sur la période
200821 347 postes ont été supprimés
cette diminution globale masque des
évolutions de structure importantes en
2011 la PGJ achève son recentrage sur
seule prise en charge des mineurs
délinquants elle cessera donc de
financer la prise en charge des mineurs
en danger et des jeunes majeurs à
l'exception des mesures d'investigation
conformément à son projet stratégique
2008-21 je ferai trois observations qui
appellent autant d'interrogation
première remarque le recentral de la pig
pénal sur la période
2008-2011 s'est accompagné des
renforcements de la prise en charge des
mineurs délinquants les crédits de cette
action augmentent de 27 %. il était
rendu nécessaire par l'évolution de la
délinquence des mineurs le nombre de
mineurs confiés au pénal à la PGJ a en
effet augmenté de 40 % entre 2002 et
2009 l'accent mis par la PGJ sur
l'amélioration de la prise en charge en
charge éducative des mineurs délinquants
s'est traduit par un renforcement des
équipes
éducatives par une diminution globale
des délais de prise en charge
même si d'important disparité notamment
monsieur le ministre je vous le rappelle
comme j'ai pu le faire en commission
dans la région r ALP sur le territoire
national demeure notamment dans les
régions urbaines et par une
concentration des moyens importants au
profit des structures accueillant les
mineurs les plus difficiles je pense en
particulier au centre éducatif fermés
aux établissement pénitentiaire pour
mineurs dans un contexte de réduction
budgétaire ce mouvement a été permis par
l'imputation d'une grande partie des
réductions budgétaires sur les fonctions
support qui ont subit une baisse de 18 %
de leur crédit en 3 ans par la fin des
prises en charge au civil et enfin par
un effort de rationalisation de l'offre
sur l'ensemble du territoire avec la
fermeture de structure inadapé et je
rappelle pas notamment la réorganisation
administrative qui est intervenue
aujourd'hui ce mouvement ce mouvement
semble atteindre ses limites
aussi Monsieur le Ministre toute
nouvelle baisse des crédits risquerait
d'affecter le taux d'encadrement des
mineurs et la qualité de leur prise en
charge je rappelle en effet en milieu
ouvert qu'un éducateur prend dors et
déjà en charge 25,1 % de M 25,1 mineur
en moyenne ce qui est au-delà de la
cible fixée de 25 mineurs en foyer la
masse salariale représente l'essentiel
des dépenses dès lors l'amélioration des
taux d'occupation des structure
constitue aujourd'hui l'unique levier
des maîtrises des coûts dans un contexte
d'augmentation tendantielle de la
population pénale la commission des lois
considère qu'il est indispensable que
les crédits de la PGJ fassent désormais
l'objet d'une stabilisation au risque de
se voir développer un effet de ciseau
qui serait préjudiciable à la qualité de
la prise en charge des mineurs
délinquants et à terme à l'objectif de
la la délinquence juvénile c'est
d'ailleurs la raison pour laquelle la
Commission a estimé que l'amendement de
notre collègue Roland de luir qui tente
à prélever 7
milli,5 d'euros sur le budget de la PGJ
ça correspondrait à 1 % du budget de la
pGG afin d'abonder les crédits du
programme justice judiciaire risquerait
de mettre celle-ci dans une situation
délicate ces observations suscitent ma
première question si entre 2008 et 2011
un pGG a rempli les objectifs assignés
par son premier projet stratégique
national quelles seront les orientations
retenues monsieur le ministre par le
second projet stratégique de la PGJ qui
devrait orienter l'action de cette
dernière au cours de la période
2012-24 2e observation comme je le
soulignais d'importants moyens humains
et financiers ont été consacrés à la
mise en place et au fonctionnement des
centres éducatifs fermés et des EPM nous
avons constaté avec collègues Alina
bomedien Thierry et Jean-René luerf la
qualité et la diversité des projets mis
en œuvre lors de notre visite à l' PM
d'ovreau et au CF de doueville toutefois
un constat s'impose un placement en CF
et unepm coûte très cher or aucune étude
n'a encore permis de mesurer l'incidence
de ces prises en charge sur la récidive
et la réinsertion des mineurs concernés
en outre plusieurs personnes entendu au
cours des auditions considèrent que cet
effort budgétaire
important s'effectue au détriment des
foyers traditionnels et des mesures en
milieu ouvert il est vrai que plusieurs
foyers troptit inadapté ont été fermés
les associations s'inquiètent également
de la baisse des crédits mobilisés en
faveur des investigations et des
réparations pénales alors même qu'une
réforme et une revalorisation de ces
mesures est en cours monsieur le
ministre la diminution des crédit
imposés à la PGJ ne risque-t-elle pas de
freiner la mise en œuvre de la réforme
des mesures d'investigation et des
mesures de réparation pénale voir de
fragiliser les services qui les
exécutent ma dernière remarque concerne
la prise en charge de minur en danger
des jeunes majeurs en 2011 la PGJ
cessera de prendre en charge et de
financer des mesures d'assistance
éducativ ordonné par les juges des
enfants ainsi que les mesures
judiciaires de protection des jeunes
majeurs l'incidence budgétaire de cette
évolution n'a pas été évalué comme l'a
regretté la Cour des comptes dans un
rapport de septembre 2009 en outre de
très grandes disparités existent dans la
manière dont les départements exécutent
les mesures judiciaires de protection il
m'a pas été possible de savoir si le
désengagement de la PGJ s'était traduit
ou non par un accroissement équivalent
des dispositifs de prise en charge par
les services des social à l'enfance il
appartient donc à la PGJ dans le rôle de
coordinateur de l'ensemble des acteur de
la de la justice des mineurs a été
consacré de s'en assurer j'attire à
nouveau votre attention sur le fait que
la frontière entre mineurs délinquants
et mineurs en danger est souvent tenue
d'après les informations qui m'ont été
communiquées 15 % des mineurs prises en
charge au pénal je termine madame ont
été présent précédemment suivi par un
juge des enfants et assistance
judiciaire la prise en charge au pénal
peut également être l'occasion pour
l'institution judiciaire de découvrir
les graves difficultés sociales d'un
mineur pour ceci la relation de
confiance qui se noue avec une équipe
d'éducateurs est essentielle ils ne
peuvent pas passer d'une case à l'autre
pour ces mineurs ne pourrait-on pas
envisager de réserver des crédits pour M
mettre à la PGJ à titre exceptionnel de
continuer à les prendre en charge en
assexance éducative ou en protection
jeunes majeur après la fin de la mesure
pénale teles sont les observations de
votre commission et sous réserve de
celle-ci la commission des lois émis un
avis favorable à l'adoption des crédits
de la projection judiciaire de la
jeunesse je voudrais tout de même en
profiter madame la président idente pour
rendre encore une fois comme je le fais
d'habitude un hommage très appuyé au
personnel de la PGJ aux éducateurs qui
travaillent dans les 1300 centres
éducatifs ouvert ou fermés je vous
remercie merci mes chers collègues je
vous rappelle que le temps de parole
attribué à chaque groupe pour chaque
discussion comprend le temps
d'intervention générale et celui de
l'explication de vote je vous rappelle
qu'en application des décisions de la
conférence des présidents aucune
intervention des orateurs des groupes ne
doit dépasser 10 minutes par ailleurs le
gouvernement dispose au total de 20
minutes pour
intervenir la parole est à Madame Nicole
borvauat
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues alors les
rapporteurs sont assez critique tout
compte fait mais propose de
voter le budget de la justice dans le
cadre de la politique générale de
réduction des dépenses
publiques cependant il y a un
problème oui a il y en a plusieurs c'est
que la politique pénale et les choix de
la majorité crée des obligations et que
ces obligations de la justice on voit
bien qu'elles sont de plus de plus en
plus difficiles à tenir alors on
pourrait débattre des choix mais ils
sont ce qu'il sont pour l'instant or on
se il faut situer ce budget dans le
cadre justement de la réponse aux
obligations on constate alors en ce qui
nous concerne nous ne voterons contre ce
budget même si il y a une augmentation
de
4,4 % pourquoi parce que quand on
regarde vous qui aimez les comparaisons
européennes surtout quand elles sont
elles nous sont favorables vous voyez
que on voit bien que dans le dernier
rapport de la Commission européenne pour
l'efficacité de la justice on peut voir
les ce qui est consternant que notre
pays se situe dans les au 37e rang des
pays du Conseil de l'Europe pour les
moyens alloués à la justice que si on
prend les augmentations voyez toute
chose égale par ailleurs si je puis dire
les augmentations entre 2006 et 2008 que
ce soit sur le les services judiciaires
que ce soit les juges professionnels le
les fonctionnaires de justice encore une
fois les crédits euh de alloués par
notre pays proportionnellement bien
entendu nombre d'habitants sont toujours
très en dessous d'autres pays qu'
comparable et même peut-être plus en en
plus grande difficulté que le nôtre donc
il y a bien un
problème prenons la justice judiciaire
ces crédits augmentent de 4,4 % après
avoir réduit les créations de postes de
magistrat à partir de 2009 vous
supprimez 76 postes en 2011 et seulement
80 postes ont été ouverts chaque année
au concours depuis 2008 vous supprimez
196 emplois de catégorie C alors qu'il
en manque pourtant l'activité judiciaire
croit personne ne peut dire le contraire
devant notre commission des finances le
15 juin votre prédécesseur a donné des
chiffres de 2002 à 2008 plus 58 %
d'affaires civiles plus 10 % d'affaires
pénales elle ajouté or parallèlement le
budget n'a augmenté que de 5 %. c'est
des regrets mais c'est voilà donc on est
dans cette situation le nombre de
greffiers augmente certes mais le ratio
greffier magistrat passera de 0,86 10 à
0,92 % c'est totalement dérisoire déjà
des audiences se tiennent sans greffier
la visioconférence d'abord elle n'est
pas en place mais elle ne règlera rien
et éloignera les justiciables de leurs
juges c'est une conception de la justice
que je désapprouve totalement la réserve
judiciaire voulue par le gouvernement
relève du bricolage pour tenter de
paliier l'insuffisance des personnels
les frais de justice ont été
sous-évalués ça fait des années qu'on
entend la même chose et des juridictions
sont sont en situation de quasi faillite
je note au passage que des analyses
génétiques il à l'élargissement constant
du périmètre du fneg sont coûteuses mais
c'est vous qui l'avez décidé ben votre
gouvernement le précédent est celui-ci
ajoutons l'annonce et déjà la réalité
ouci ou là du désengagement du ministère
de l'Intérieur dans la sécurité des
audiences et des tribunaux le Livre
blanc de l'Union Syndicale des
Magistrats est tout à fait édifiant sur
la misère matérielle de nombreuses
juridictions les dit pour l'accès au
droit et à la justice augmente de 12,35
% mais au seul bénéfice de l'aide
juridictionnelle pour couvrir
l'augmentation de la TVA qui a été passé
chez les pour les avocats de 5 5 à 19
encore une un effet de la politique de
la majorité actuelle ce pour le réseau
judiciaire de proximité diminue et avec
2,5 million d'euros le budget d'
médiation familiale est dérisoire pour
tenir compte de la réforme à venir une
augmentation de la part de l'aide
juridictionnelle consacrée à la garde à
vue a été annoncée elle passerait de 15
à 80 millions d'euros mais la
Chancellerie table sur l'hypothèse d'une
réduction de moitié du nombre des gardes
à vu une hypothèse audacieuse tant mieux
le fait d'avoir des objectifs audacieux
c'est bien ceci dit on on est loin d'en
être là et ça se fera pas dans le budget
2011 il n'est pas exclu que l'audition
libre soit censurée comme non conforme à
l'exigence de présence de l'avocat et
personnellement c'est ce que je souhaite
pour la construction et la maintenance
de palais justice l'appel au Partenariat
Public Privé semble devenir la règle
quand Perpignan Lille Paris ou bouig et
Vinc se disputent le marché alors que la
Cour des comptes dénonce le coût
prohébitif des partenariats publics
privés ainsi en est-il on continue si
les crédits de l'administration
pénitentiaire bénéficie d'une
augmentation de 4,4 % et de
l'essentielle des créations d'emplois
elle est essentiellement liée à
l'ouverture de nouveaux établissements
or la loi pénitentiaire entre en
application pourtant modeste elle est
déjà contredite par le budget cuite de
l'obligation d'activité du travail de la
formation professionnelle des détenus
cuit de leur accès aux soins des
aménagements de peinees et de la
réinsertion dans son étude d'impact la
loi le confirme il faudrait recruter
cela a été dit un millier de conseillers
pour un fonctionnement normal des
services pénitentiaires d'insertion et
de probation les crédits prévu ne
couvriront pas même même pas plutôt les
départs en retraite face à
l'accroissement de la charge de travail
il manque 800 personnel administratif ce
projet en prévoit environ 80 il manque
150 personnel technique mais vous ne
voulez vous voulez les faire disparaître
avec la gestion privée mais la gestion
privée ça se paye et il semble on peut
constater que ça se paye assez cher et
c'est dans cette situation très dégradée
que l'administration pénitentiaire SOA
transférer le transfert les détenus vers
les juridictions et les hôpitaux et la
garde de certains lieux nouvell prison
nouvelle unité pour personnes détenues
atteintes de troublementau l'enfermement
demeure prioritaire l'enfermement ça
coûte vous fermez 45 établissements
pénitentiaires et en ouvrez une
vingtaine pour accueillir 14000 détenus
des structures donc de grande taille où
la technique prime sur l'humain
centralisée et privatisée pourtant
CORBA pose déjà des problèmes au
personnel et au détenus et beaucoup
s'accordent que les petites structures
sont plus adaptées évidemment le privé
va y trouver bénéfice d'une part en
rachetant des sites fermé d'autre part
avec la poursuite du recours au
partenariat public privé alors que le
coût de gestion délégué a progressé de
13 % alors voyez ils sont bien au-delà
eux de la progression des budgets de la
justice 13 % de 2006 à 2008 la
progression de la gestion privée donc
pas de problème sur la fuite en avant ce
budget dégradera encore les conditions
de travail des personnels et les
conditions de vie des détenus et des
personnes suivies par les spips les
personnels ont alerté ils alertent ils
continuent d'alerter on est dans une
situation dangereuse le gouvernement
parle beaucoup de la délinquance des
bineurs et de sa prévention mais les
crédits de la PGJ cela vient d'être dit
baisse pour la 3è fois - 2 % - 117
équivalant temp
plein vous tentez de justifier cette
baisse par le recentrage de la PGJ sur
prise en charge des mineurs abandonnant
au conseils généraux les mineurs en
danger et les jeunes majeurs les
associations regroupées au sein de
l'uniops s'inquiète d'une mise en cause
de la cohérence et la continuité
nécessaire entre la prise en charge
civile et pénale du jeûe elle pointe le
désengagement de la PGJ dans le
dispositif d'assistance éducative la
baisse des crédits pour à la répartition
pénale des mineurs à la réparation
pénale des mineurs et à
l'investigation dans le même temps vous
concentrer les moyens sur les
établissements pénitentiaires pour
mineurs et centes éducatif fermés sans
aucune réelle évaluation il est pas il
est pas acceptable de dire on constate
que pas de récidive parce qu'il faut le
comparer à d'autres dispositifs dans ce
rapport rendu public en juillet la
Défenseur des enfants fait le constat
que des adolescents sont confiés au CF
non pour leur profil de jeunes
récidivistes ou multiréitérant mais en
raison de l'absence d'une solution
alternative à l'incarcération du fait
des nombreuses fermetures
d'établissements qui ne soi pas qui ne
sont pas des CFS donc si vous voulez il
y a un déplacement de population donc
c'est pas juste de dire qu'il y a des
résultats ce projet de budget contredit
ses préconisations j'ajoute qu'au 1er
novembre 2010 le nombre de mineurs
incarcérés
accru ils sont euh
695 ce projet de budget de la PGJ est
significative de la volonté des
gouvernements qui se succèdent et de la
majorité parlementaire depuis 2002 de
vider peu à peu de sa Raon d'être la
justice des mineurs et ça c'est
effectivement c'est évidemment très
grave nous avons donc tout à craindre de
la réforme qui est en préparation donc
pour toutes ces raisons nous voterons
contre les crédits de la mission justice
merci madame la Présidente la parole est
à Monsieur Laurent
betteille
bonjour
madame le Président monsieur le garde
des saau mes chers collègues d'abord je
voudrais féliciter monsieur le ministre
pour ses nouvelles fonctions lui dire
tout le le plaisir qu'on a à le voir
exercer ses
responsabilités la la discussion que
nous entamons aujourd'hui sur la mission
justice est l'occasion pour nous de
constater que le budget de la justice
reste cette année encore une des grandes
priorit é du gouvernement et le groupe
UMP se félicite que pour la 7e année
consécutive ce budget soit en
augmentation
sensible ainsi l'engagement du président
en faveur d'un rapprochement de la
justice et du citoyen se concrétise à
travers ce budget qui va atteindre
7illards 128 millions d'euros soit une
augmentation de 4,15 % en crédit de
paiement à ce titre je tiens à souligner
les efforts réalisés par notre majorité
en faveur de la justice alors même que
le contexte budgétaire mes chers
collègues ne s'y prête guerre vous le
savez bien les crédits des programmes
justice judiciaaires accès au droit et à
la justice conduite et pilotage de la
politique de la justice progresse
respectivement de 4,4 % 12,3 % et 7 %.
nous nous réjouissons de l'augmentation
substantielle de ces crédits qui
permettront de renforcer les moyens de
nos institutions judiciaires ainsi
l'administration pénit ancire et le
secteur judiciaire voit leurs effectifs
croître en ce sens
nousouvons le rééquilibrage du ratio
greffier magistrat dans le milieu
judiciaire et la création de 400 postes
de
greffier ce budget répond à plusieurs
interrogations notamment celle émise
dans le milieu carcéral à l'issue de la
loi pénitentiaire ce secteur voit
conjointement la création de 413 emplois
le départ le remplacement des départs à
la retraite ainsi que des déploiement
ceci aboutira à l'affectation de 1000
emplois additionnels pour l'année à
venir cet accroissement ne peut qu'être
saluer au moment où la loi pénitentiaire
que notre majorité peut se féliciter
d'avoir adopté requierre d'une part que
des établissements pénitencière soi
construit et d'autre part que les
missions traditionnelles soient mieux
adaptées aux solutions alternatives à
l'emprisonnement contenu dans le texte
de la loi l'ampleur des changements tels
que le recentrage des services
pénitencière et de probation sur la
prévention de la récidive ou encore la
priorité donnée à la prise en charge des
mineurs délinquants nécessiter un
déploiement financier plus important ces
choses faites à travers ce projet de loi
de finance pour 2011 et ce je le répète
malgré un contexte budgétaire qui
appelle aux restrictions si nous
approuvons cette politique de
modernisation favorable à un
rééquilibrage des crédits de personnels
je souhaite vous questionner monsieur le
ministre sur la question des crédits de
fonctionnement en effet de nombreuses
difficultés sont soulevées dans les
bâtiments de justice notamment en raison
des frais de gestion disproportionnés au
regard du budget àoué c'est pourquoi
j'aimerais savoir Monsieur le Ministre
les solutions que vous envisagez
d'apporter à ces difficultés de gestion
que connaissent les tribunaux il est en
effet essentiel de donner les moyens
matériels suffisants pour que la justice
soit rendue dans des condition condition
les meilleurs possibles il en va de la
qualité et de la rapidité aussi de notre
système
judiciaire moderniser notre appareil
judiciaire c'est aussi renouveler
l'immobilier
pénitentiaire sur ce sujet le groupe UMP
salue le volontarisme du gouvernement en
effet à travers plusieurs programmes
immobiliers de construction notre pays
devrait disposer en 2017 de 68000 places
en prison sachant qu'aujourd'hui nous en
avons 61 nous avons 6 000 personnes
incarcérées en plus des investissements
extra budgétaires le budget pour 2011
poursuit dans le bon sens l'inscription
de crédit de paiement pour les
investissements cela revient à 331
millions d'euros pour l'immobilier
pénitentiaire et 200 millions d'euros
pour la réhabilitation de tribunaux
vetust nous devons faire ces choix pour
le renouvellement de notre parc
immobilier judiciaire car il n'est pas
acceptable d'avoir en France des
conditions de détention qui dans
certaines maisons d'arrêt portent
atteinte à la dignité de la personne et
par la même à la dignité de notre patrie
des Droits de l'Homme au-delà de
l'examen du budget consacré à notre
système carcéral je souhaiterais aborder
plus particulièrement la question de la
prise en charge des personnes atteint de
troubles mentaux et ayant commis une
infraction en effet l'excellent rapport
du groupe de travail dédié à ce sujet et
rapporté par nos collègues Jean-René
leer Christianne de montè Bert barbier
et Jean-Pierre Michel relève que la
prise en charge de ces détenus repose
actuellement sur premièrement des unités
de consultation et de soins ambulatoires
qui assurent les soins courants dans les
établissements pénitentiaires de leur
zone géographique d'autre part les
services médicau-psychologiques
régionaux basés principalement maison
d'arrêt et chargé des soins
psychiatriques et de préparation du
suivi post-pénal et enfin des unités
hospitalières spécialement aménagées qui
permettent une hospitalisation des
détenus équivalente à celle qui prévaut
en dehors du milieu carcéral si dans
leur rapport ne collègues reconnaissent
les efforts réalisés ces dernières
années il montre également que le milieu
carcéral peut-être un lieu d'aggravation
de certaines pathologie en l'absence de
structures adaptées aux soins
psychiatriques c'est pourquoi Monsieur
le Ministre à l'heure où la justice est
en forte évolution et en vue des futures
réalisations immobilières nous
souhaiterions connaître votre engagement
sur ce
sujet enfin moderniser notre appareil
judiciaire c'est rapprocher nos
concitoyens de la justice ce
rapprochement passe évidemment par
l'accès à la justice qui plus est légal
accès à la justice ceci m'amène à
intervenir sur la question de l'aide
juridictionnelle les crédits qui sont
affectés sur le PLF pour 2011 font
l'objet d'une forte augmentation pour
atteindre
312,3 million d'euros mais cette hausse
s'explique essentiellement par
l'application du taux normal de la TVA
pour les missions effectuées par les
avocats nous nous réjouissons de cette
hausse qui permettra une meilleure prise
en charge de l'aide juridictionnelle
afin de promouvoir l'accès à la justice
au plus défut favorisés mais avec quand
même l'inquiétude de savoir si ce sera
encore suffisant cependant si les crédit
augmente et que l'instauration d'un
ticket
modérateur susceptible de limiter les
abus de cours
infondé il reste néanmoins un problème
il s'agit du recouvrement de l'
juridictionnelle auprès de la partie qui
perd son procès actuellement l'utilité
financière de cette procédure se révèle
quasiment nulle en raison du manque de
temps et de moyens qui sont affectés dès
lors monsieur le garde des saau
pouvez-vous nous préciser vos ambitions
pour que le recouvrement de ces frais
puissent devenir
efficient monsieur le garde des saau mes
chers collègues c'est parce que ce
budget fondé sur une optimisation de la
gestion des ressources financières a
pour objet de conforter les
professionnels de la justice et de
rendre au justiciables toute la
confiance qu'ils doivent avoir dans nos
institutions judiciaires que le groupe
UMP votera les crédits de la mission
justice je vous remercie merci mon cher
collègue la parole est à Monsieur
Jean-Pierre
suur
la
présid madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers
collègues monsieur le ministre au moment
où vous accédez à cette haute fonction
de garde des saau je veux d'abord vous
présenter mes vœux de pleine réussite
dans votre mission très importante pour
notre pays en même temps je veux
souligner que ces vœux sont d'autant
plus sincères que je sais que l'héritage
est
lourd
car je ne vais pas reprendre ce qu'a dit
notre collègue madame
Borvo tout à
l'heure nous avons lu aussi monsieur le
rapporteur
que dans son 4e rapport
biannuel la Commission européenne pour
l'efficacité de la
justice nous a placé au 37e rang alors
que l'année dernière nous étions au 35e
rang et
que dans ce pays nous ne dépensons que
0,16 % de la richesse du PIB pour la
justice ce qui nous classe derrière
l'Arménie et l'Azerbaïdjan on ne peut
pas dire qu'il y ait motif madame Goulet
à
pavoiser j'ai remarqué que pour 100000
habitants il y avait
9,1 juges en France et là nous sommes au
43e rang donc il faut relever le défi et
je crois monsieur le ministre que votre
tâche pourrait
être d'affirmer qu'il faut une rupture
pour le coup puisqu'on a beaucoup
entendu parler de rupture par le passé
une rupture c'est-à-dire qu'il faut que
notre pays décide dans un contexte
financier très difficile quels sont les
champs ministériels pour lesquels il
faut véritablement augmenter les moyens
et moi je mettrai au premier rang la
justice l'enseignement supérieur la re
cherche parce que ce sont des champs où
nous
sommes confrontés à des défis très
lourds alors Monsieur le le ministre
vous avez suffisamment siégé dans notre
assemblée et dans d'autres assemblées
pour savoir que pour relever le défi il
faut naturellement refuser les petites
méthodes et les
subterfuge naturellement nous avons bien
vu que le budget augmenté de 4,2
%.
mais les reports des suppressions de
crédits de 2010 sur
2011 sont pris en compte
induement ce qui fait que le 4,2 % n'est
plus tout à fait le même et chacun aura
compris cela et vous le
premier de même on ne peut guerre se
glorifier enfin on peut le faire
formellement et j'espère que dans votre
votre discours vous allez dire la vérité
on peut dire les frais de justice
augmentent de 17 %. mais comme chacun a
bien compris que l'année dernière ils
étaient dramatiquement sous-évalués si
bien qu'on a dû affecter 19 millions
d'euros de crédit personnel pour payer
ce qu'il fallait payer qu'on ne pouvait
pas payer dans les frais de justice le
plus 17 % est évidemment en trompe l'œil
cela ne vous a pas plus trompé que
nous-mêmes de même pour ce qui est des
emplois de la PGJ il y a 117 emplois de
moins 20 millions de budget de moins nos
collègues en ont parlé naturellement
nous savons qu'il y a une nouvelle
distribution des tâches par rapport aux
conseils généraux mais je ne vais pas
expliquer au au président de conseil
général que vous êtes par ailleurs les
grandes difficultés auxquelles sont
confrontés les conseils généraux et donc
euh il est difficile de dire que tout va
pour le mieux dans le le meilleur des
mondes d'ailleurs
j'observe que notre rapporteur monsieur
du Luar que je tiens à saluer tout
particulièrement a fait un rapport qui
présente de grandes de grandes envolet
de
lucidité je parlais des des frais de
justice je lis dans le rapport de
Monsieur Duluard il apparaît
donc que la S budgétisation constatée en
2009 et 2010 se poursuit en 2011
remettant en cause le principe de
sincérité budgétaire au sein de la
mission justice et je sais que Monsieur
Duluard est très avisé et je pense qu'il
ne parle pas de sincérité par hasard ce
n'est pas un mot
anodin de même
d'ailleurs ah je dis avec beaucoup
d'attention s'agissant des postes de
magistrats
nous voyons qu'il y en a 76 de moins
alors naturellement notre rapporteur
monsieur
Duluard a dit que le ratio entre le
nombre de greffiers et celui de
magistrat n'a pas pu atteindre le niveau
souhaitable de 1 pour un ce ratio reste
durablement défavorable au greffi comme
on atteste le tableau suivant et dans ce
tableau que que j'ai regardé en 2006 le
ratio était de 0,88 et en 2010 de
0,86 donc on est en baisse alors
naturellement monsieur le ministre je
dis ça pour l'année prochaine comme le
nombre de magistrra baisse de
76 on peut prévoir que le ratio va
augmenter l'an prochain mais vous
comprendrez que celui qui dira nous
constatons que le ratio augmente dira
quelque chose qui n'a bien entendu aucun
fondement quand on a fait un peu de
mathématique élémentaire tout cela pour
vous dire mes chers collègues
monsieur le ministre que nous pourrions
continuer à à citer des chiffres la
vérité c'est qu'il faut changer les
choses et qu'il faut donner plus de
moyens à ce ministère c'est une totale
nécessité je pense que tout le monde
sera d'accord
là-dessus dans mon département la presse
s'est fait l'écho d'une
erreur C trafiquants de stupéfiants
présumés remis de
par
erreur je sais que l'inspection générale
de vos services monsieur le ministre
vient inspecé à Orléan aujourd'hui même
par rapport à cet événement qui a
suscité des réaction et bien entendu qui
suscite aussi l'incompréhension par
rapport nos l'incompréhension de nos
concitoyens je pense que il est tout à
fait juste d'établir les
responsabilités c'est le rôle de
l'inspection je pense qu'elle le fera
euh sans faire aucune démagogie à cet
égard euh il faut replacer cela dans un
contexte où dès le mois de mai dernier
les chefs de cours et les chef de
juridiction à Orléan ont alerté votre
prédécesseur monsieur le ministre avec
beaucoup
d'insistance s'agissant des problèmes de
personnel de manque de personnel et de
manque de moyens
et autant je pense qu'il faut bien
entendu trouver les
responsabilités sur cette erreur qui est
tout à fait fâcheuse c'est le moins
qu'on puisse dire
autant il faut prendre en compte le
contexte et ce contexte c'est qu'il y a
un manque de personnel de fonctionnaires
de greffiers de magistrats et que cela
se traduit par un certain nombre de
dysfonctionnement et se traduira par des
dysfonctionnements nouveaux si il n'y a
pas des mesures énergiques de prise
quant aux moyens de votre ministère je
terminerai madame la Présidente en vous
disant que bien entendu au-delà de ces
considérations
budgétaires nous attendons de vous que
vous puissiez peut-être mettre en œuvre
cette collégialité par rapport au juge
d'instruction qui figure dans la loi que
nous attendons de vous monsieur le
ministre que
la législation absolument nécessaire sur
la garde à vue arrive
rapidement pourquoi parce que nous
sommes dans une situation absurde où le
Conseil constitutionnel a déclaré que
les gardes- à vu qui ont lieu
actuellement sont inconstitutionnelles
et néanmoins elles peuvent se poursuivre
encore quelques mois mais ce qui crée
une instabilité juridique et conduit un
nombre important tant d'avocat à saisir
la Cour européenne des droits de l'homme
cette situation ne peut pas durer donc
c'est absolument URGENT Nous serions
intéressés monsieur le ministre par une
précision que j'ai l'honneur de vous
demander de solliciter auprès de vous en
concluant cette
intervention s'agissant de l'idée de
supprimer les juges
d'instruction qui aarissait cher à votre
prédécesseur nous avons noté avec tié
que lors de votre premier discours
devant une organisation de magistrats
vous n'en aviez point
parlé alors ce silence a été diversement
interprété et pour ma part je l'ai
interprété madame la la Présidente je
fini je l'ai interprété comme signifiant
que vous aviez renoncé à cette funeste
idée de supprimer les juges
d'instruction et je seraiis heureux ce
serait au moins l'un des points
importants de ce débat si vous pouviez
nous confirmer monsieur le ministre que
tel est bien votre position je vous en
remercie merci mon chers collègu la
parole est à Monsieur Jacques
mzard madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre que nous félicitons pour votre
nomination comme ministre de la Justice
et des Libertés mes chers
collègues le président de l'USM déclaré
voici quelques jours que votre ministère
était sinistré sur le plan
budgétaire avec des personnels au mieux
désabusés au pire
ulcéré régression et consternation
quotidienne avec Madame Datti période de
stagnation et de déception ensuite en
réalité monsieur le ministre ce projet
le budget 2011 c'est le produit de deux
héritages pour une fois ce que nous
attendons c'est la rupture mais elle n'y
est pas encore et c'est pour cela que
nous voterons majoritairement contre ce
budget soyons néanmoins très conscient
que si la justice va mal qu'elle est
dans le wagon de queue des pays
européens c'est beaucoup parce que nos
concitoyens n'en font une priorité que
lorsqu'ils sont directement
concernés qu'attendons-nous de la
justice
qu'elle soit indépendante
professionnelle accessible à tous quel
que soit le niveau social ou le lieu de
résidence qu'elle assure le respect des
droits de la personne des victimes de la
liberté individuelle des lois de la
République qu'en matière pénale la
sanction soit proportionnelle à la faute
que cette sanction soit
exécutée avec la dignité qui
convient comparer ce programme à ce qui
a été réalisé ces dernières années
c'est en grande partie
l'inverse insécurité juridique par une
véritable diarrée législative en
particulier dans le domaine pénal où
l'accumulation de dizaines de textes
sécuritaires à vocation médiatique a
rendu l'application de la loi par le
magistrat
périlleuse par des lois placardisé avant
même d'être
expérimenté par une résistance insensée
a appliqué la jurisprudence de la Cour
européenne et même disons-le la loi
pénitentiaire très consensuelle initiée
par notre collègue Jean-René leer par
des réformes qui se bousculent se
contredisent souvent de la création des
juges de proximité à la suppression de
178 tribunaux d'instance par des
réformes concernant les professions
judiciaire qui se caractérise par la
priorité donnée au droit des affaires au
monde des affaires et non au
citoyens par un affichage des lois de
répression alors qu'un nombre
considérable et vous le savez de
condamnations ne sont jamais exécutées
et ce de manière diverse selon le
territoire en
plus face à ce constat qui ne vous est
pas imputable monsieur le ministre
est-il opportun pour freudonet tout va
très bien Madame la marquise de
s'engager vers de pseudo innovations
comme les jurés dans les tribunaux
correctionnels n'est-il pas plus urgent
de remettre en ordre de marche la
justice en lui redonnant confiance en
elle-même en ses magistrats en son
personnel en ses auxiliaires c'est ainsi
qu'elle retrouvera la confiance des
citoyens mettrai l'accent sur quelques
points
significatifs administration
pénitentiaire il est globalement positif
de constater une légère diminution du
nombre de des détenus et un
développement des mesures
alternatives en revanche notre
rapporteur a mis en évidence que le
budget était très déconnecté de la loi
pénitentiaire alors que celle-ci
constitue un progrès incontestable un
choix de fond est à réaliser monsieur le
ministre pour nous il convient de
développer les services pénitentiaires
d'insertion et de probation ainsi que
l'obligation d'activité et de
s'interroger sur la pertinence du
nouveau programme de 5000 places il y a
tant à faire pour moderniser l'existant
quant à la fermeture des maisons d'arrêt
considéré comme exemplaire par notre
rapporteur sous le prétexte de la RGPP
et d'une interprétation fallacieuse de
l'encellulement individuel j'attends de
votre part monsieur le ministre
l'application de votre bon sens je
crains que cela soit difficile d'autre
part le transfert des escortes
judiciaires pour des raisons non
techniques va entraîner de graves
difficultés le budget ne fait pas
apparaître l'impact financier de la
politique de déjudiciarisation engagée
ces dernières années et amplifié
subreptissement par des lois dites de
simplification c'est ainsi que nombre
d'actes ont été retirés au GREF pour les
confier le plus souvent au notairire
avec des conséquences pour les plus
démunis quel est pacte en équivalent
temp plein allez-vous persévérer dans
cette voie encore utilisée récemment
pour faire passer au notaire la pilule
de l'acte d'avocat le budget intègre le
coût de la carte judiciaire sans que
l'on évalue précisément les gains de
cette réforme et on népiloguera pas sur
le coûte du nouveau TGI de Paris
monsieur le ministre il n'y a rien dans
le budget qui permettra de stopper la
désertification judiciaire engagée par
vos prédécesseurs
les petits départements deviennent
sinistrés en matière judiciaire comme
ils le sont en matière médicale
suppression des tribunaux postees non
pourvu regroupement de juridiction
spécialisé dans les métropoles
papérisation des auxiliiare de justice
avec comme conséquence de nombreux
citoyens de plus en plus éloignés du
droit à la justice particulièrement en
matière pénale notamment pour les plus
démunis votre conception de l'AM du
territoire monsieur le ministre n'est
pas compatible avec ce budget pour
rendre une bonne justice il faut des
professionnels qualifié en nombre
suffisant avec des moyens suffisants or
comme le relève l'ensemble des
rapporteurs j'allais dire dans leur
réquisition le projet annuel de
performance pour 2011 supprime 76
emplois de magistrat vous avez marqué la
la nécessité d'une gestion
prévisionnelle des emplois ce n'est pas
la création d'une réserve judiciaire qui
Piera les départs à la retraite non
compensé le fonctionnement de nos
tribunaux va continuer à se dégrader et
l'effet de ciseau est hélas
inéluctable il est aussi à noter que les
promesses faites aux avoués à leurs
salariés ne sont pas tenus et ne le
seront pas j'en viens monsieur le
ministre au problème de l'aide
juridictionnelle il est crucial non
seulement ce budget ne le résout
aucunement mais il n'anticipe pas
vraiment le choc que devra être la
réforme de la garde à vue si les moyens
financiers ne sont pas débloqués nous
irons vers un simulacre de réforme et
une aggravation de l'insécurité
juridique oublions le rapport d'arois
serait-il raisonnable de demander au PDG
de LVMH un rapport sur les conditions de
vie d'un smicard ce ne serait pas
raisonnable il n'est d'autres solutions
à défaut de nouvelles taxes sur des
actes que d'effectuer un prélèvement
conséquent sur le pactol des assureur
dans le domaine de la protection
juridique et de faire gérer le produit
par la profession judiciaire cela nous
conduit naturellement au dossier de la
garde- à vue les fortins défensifs mis
en place par la Chancellerie
s'effondrent l'un après l'autre sous les
coups de toutes les juridictions
européennes et nationales le compte à
rebours accélère l'arrêt de la Cour
européenne du 23 novembre 2010 dans
l'affaire moulin sonne le glas de tout
un système on murmure pourtant
que la Commission réunie en votre
ministère en grande discrétion ce même
23 novembre au matin e comme objectif la
validation du projet de réforme du du
code de procédure pénale sur la base du
rapport léger au mépris des arrêts de
Strasbourg est-ce vrai un mot pour
conclure monsieur le ministre sur
l'article 75 du projet de loi de
finances qui reporte au 1er janvier 2014
la mise en œuvre de la collégialité de
l'instruction n'est-ce pas un cavalier
législatif ou plutôt un escadron je
rappelle que la loi du 5 mars 2007 fut
votée unanimement et qu'elle est
pulvérisée au motif invoqué et reconnu
du projet de suppression du juge
d'instruction pour finir puis-je vous
lire en
conclusion la conclusion du président
Jean-Louis Debray dans son livre les
magistrats au 19e siècle je le cite en
contestant au juges le droit à
l'indépendance en muselant toutes les
véités d'autonomie des magistrats du
parquet en confondant le service de
l'État et celui du gouvernement les
hommes politiques du 19e siècle sont à
l'origine de la crise de la magistrature
et de la justice qui sévira au 20e
siècle la situation a-t-elle vraiment
changé je ne le pense pas merci ch
collègue la parole est à Monsieur
Richard
Jung
m
surpris madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre gardeessau mes chers collègues
dans le domaine pénitentiaire les années
se suivent et se
ressemblent le premier point que je veux
traiter c'est bien sûr la politique
immobilière qui est un sujet important
nous avions suffisamment insisté sur les
conséquences de la surpopulation dans
les prisons pour ne pas nous réjouir de
voir que le projet prévoit la création
de 5000 places nouvelles dans les
prochaines années
mais permettez-moi de faire quelques
remarques à cet égard la première c'est
qu'il faut bien sûr que ces 5000 places
servent à faire baisser le taux
d'occupation
de nos prisons et ne soit pas simplement
un appel à remplir plus des prisons que
par ailleurs d'ailleurs on viderait par
des mesures de politique d'adaptation
des peines et de ce point de vue là je
vous rappelle que la prison de C a un
taux d'occupation de 200 % maotte j'ose
même pas le signaler et mon collègue
Colomba m'a demandé de vous signaler que
la prison de Draguignan qui a été
détruite par le les intempéries la
tempête n'a toujours pas connu de
semble-t-il de début de de
reconstruction et que l'opinion
varoise euh s'inquiète à cet égard
peut-être pourrez-vous nous en dire un
mot je disais donc il faut que ces
places servent à faire baisser de façon
significative le taux de surpopulation
de nos
prisons je vous dois dire d'ailleurs que
nous voyons un revirement significatif
un virement elle sur elle d'ailleurs
notre rapporteur monsieur le cerf l'a
l'a noté dans la position du
gouvernement sur la question de lancer
l'unement
individuel nous pensons que c'est un
objectif que nous devons poursuivre mais
en même temps il doit être interprété et
conçu avec intelligence avec
subtilité il y a des cas où ça n'est pas
la meilleure solution nous avons visité
tous suffisamment de prisons pour avoir
rencontré des détenus qui préfèrent être
ou à deux ou même en semi groupe donc
cela dépend des cas des situations et ça
doit être appliqué avec
discernement enfin il
faut que ces places aillent de
préférence vers des PR prison de petite
et de moyenne dimension nous nous
inquiétons de voir qu'il y a des projets
de de nouveau de grandes prison les
professionnels disent que 300 places
c'est quelque chose de raisonnable je
crois que nous devons nous nous nous
cantonner si j'ose dire dans des unités
de de cette
t au mois d'avril
dernier Monsieur Jean-Marie Boel avait
demandé à Monsieur Gontard un
rapport sur les prisons ouvertes sur le
développement des prisons ouverte en
France je crois que c'est une idée que
beaucoup d'entre nous soutiennent je
voudrais savoir où l'on en est si ce
rapport a été remis ou est-ce que le
départ de Monsieur Boel marque la fin et
l'enterrement de ce pourtant beau
concept puisque je parle des conditions
euh de vie en en prison je déposerai
tout à l'heure un amendement visant à la
gratuité de la de l'accès à la
télévision dans les centres de détention
mais nous en reparlerons à ce
moment-là ces considérations matérielles
revêent d'autant plus d'importance
qu'elles ont un effet majeur sur l'état
psychologique des personnes
détenues il est globalement mauvais nous
le savons depuis le début de l'année et
c'est quelque chose de de lourd de
terrible 150 détenus ont mis fin à leur
jour contre 115 en 2009 et 109 en
2008 la le garde des saau précédent
avait mis en place un plan de lutte
contre les suicides en prison mais j'ai
l'impression que ce plan n'a pas donner
de résultats significatif le kit ce
qu'on appelait le kit
antisuicide les pyjamas en papier et
cetera n'ont pas été des solutions à la
hauteur de cet enjeu majeur
pourriez-vous nous dire comment vous
envisagez cette
question le concept d'établissement à
réinsertion active era sur lequel
s'apura le nouveau programme immobilier
prévoit la création systématique de
locaux destiné au servicees de
psychiatrie au sein des unités de
consultation et des soins ambulatoires
j'ai personnellement des réserves sur
cette approche car à mon sens les
malades psychiatriques qui sont pourtant
nombreux 25 28 % des détenus n'ont rien
à faire en prison et à mon avis il y a
là une confusion de genre qui est
fâcheuse cela a été retenu cela a été
souligné le travail en milieu
carcéral force de constater que euh la
conjoncture économique rend difficile la
mise en œuvre de l'obligation d'activité
et l'objectif de 37 % c'est-à-dire en
fait 1/3 des des détenus au travail
n'est pas suffisant et c'est quelque
chose de tout à fait euh
dommageable je pense que la crise à
Bondo je je je conclus je pense que la
crise à bondau puisqu'on voit que dans
les pays d'Europe du Nord où la crise
est également présente et bien les taux
de emploi sont significativement plus
élevés enfin un dernier point je
m'arrêterai madame la Présidente sur le
nombre d'emploi vous créez
997 emplois
supplémentaires ce qui va dans le bon
sens mais ne sont pas comptés dans ces
emplois le transfert de l'escorte de la
gendarmerie et de la police vers
l'administration pénitentiaire selon les
cas on nous dit qu'il s'agit de 800
emplois supplémentaires qui sont
concernés si d'un côté on enc 1000 mais
que d'autre part on transfère 1200
d'emplo pour les escortes franchement le
résultat sera ou nul ou même négatif
pouvezvous nous rassurer sur ce point
voilà les principales remarques que l'on
peut faire vous comprendrez bien sr que
notre vote ne sera pas favorable merci
merci ch collèg la parole est à Madame
Virginie
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers
collègues monsieur le ministre même si
ce budget n'a pas été élaboré par
vous-même vous allez avoir la lour de
tâche et je partage là l'analyse de mon
collègue suur de le mettre en œuvre et
surtout de veiller à son efficacité en
effet c'est un budget qui a été élaboré
par un gouvernement auquel vous accordez
votre confiance cependant que j'ai moi
beaucoup de mal à le faire devant
effectivement un exécutif qui multiplie
les effets
déclamatoires qui multip multiplie les
incohérences et les contradictions qui
confond vitesse et précipitation qui
confond priorité et comptabilité
mutualisation et coupe
sombre qui se permet de commenter des
décisions de justice et qui confond
coupable et mise en cause parfois bref
qui confond le pouvoir exécutif et le
pouvoir judiciaire alors en ce qui
concerne les chiffres ils ont déjà été
beaucoup analysés et disséqué par mes
prédécesseurs à cette tribune
manifestement avec les mêmes chiffres on
peut avoir des analyses à géométrie
variable puisque je n'ai pas encore
entendu beaucoup de ministres se
plaindre de restrictions ni de coupe
sombre dans leur budget au contraire il
se félicite tous officiellement mais pas
trop fort pour PIR faire de jaloux
finalement d'avoir bien défendu leur
biftech et d'avoir obtenu des choses
très intéressantes dans leur
ministère dans un contexte de RGPP où
pourtant théoriquement tous les fonds
publics ont diminué j'ai un petit peu du
mal à comprendre la cohérence de ces
discours personnellement en tout cas je
partage plutôt le pessimisme de mes
collègues de gauche sur les fonds qui
vous ont été attribués à l'optimisme de
mes collègues de droite en tout cas
point n'est besoins sans doute
d'analyser ces chiffres de façon précise
les grands principes de ce budget
démontreront facilement les qualités que
j'ai prêté au gouvernement dans mon
propos introductif en ce qui concerne
par exemple la pénitentière
l'incohérence de ce budget se mesure à
la carte des fermetures et des
ouvertures où l'on ferme où on en tout
cas on propose de fermer des
établissements pénitentiaires qui
fonctionnent bien pour lesquels les taux
de récidif sont bas pour lesquels les
problèmes sociaux sont peu élevés pour
lesquels l'ambiance est excellente mais
on les ferme quand même Dieu seul sait
sur quelle modification et sur quelle
justification pour en construire en
ouvrir d'autres ailleurs avec une carte
géographique dont j'ai du mal aussi à
comprendre la cohérence quand on affiche
l'importance du rapprochement familial
et que l'on considère les ouvertures
prévues qui elles n'ont pas du tout
l'air de prendre en compte cette
importance du rapprochement familial le
suivi par les bracelets
électromagnétiques certes les brcelets
électromagnétiques sont prévus mais il
est de notoriété publique en tout cas
l'expérience plus ancienne que laanneau
de nos voisins étrangers le démontrre il
est nécessaire de mettre du personnel en
place pour suivre les personnes sous
bracelets électromagnétiqu parce que les
problèmes se font sur le long terme et
non pas sur les quelques mois qui
suivent la sortie de prison et
l'insertion une fois de plus se conjugue
sur le long terme quels sont les moyens
mis en place pour le suivi de ces
personnes aucun précipitation
précipitation en matière de
transférement des personnes sous main de
justice ça fait des années qu'on en
parle était-il nécessaire de le faire
brutalement en quelques mois et sans
aucun aucune concertation sans aucune
préparation sans aucune formation du
personnel à qui on va demander d'assumer
ses nouvelles missions demain une fois
de plus vitesse et précipitation ça
avait déjà été le cas pour Cassiopé ça a
déjà été le cas pour la réforme des
tutelles et on fait des réformes à côté
de l'efficacité que l'on affiche les
mineurs qui me préoccupent énormément
énormément j'ai lu avec beaucoup
d'attention le rapport de Monsieur bel
sur la prévention de la délinquence
monsieur bookel lui-même s'inquiète
énormément sur la systématisation des
comparitions immédiates
qui ne sont la plupart du temps pas en
rapport avec l'efficacité quand on parle
de situation complexes et
multifactorielle où de nombreuses choses
sont à prendre en considération si l'on
veut réellement sortir les mineurs de la
délinquence monsieur bocel lui-même
s'inquiète des des moyens qui vont être
donnés au milieu associatif monsieur
bocal lui-même s'inquiète des
incertitudes sur les mesures éducatives
qui seront demain mises en place déjà
dans nombre de juridictions les budgets
sont insuffisants pour les enquêtes
sociales les délégués du procureur ne
peuvent plus se déplac placé il n'y a
plus de budget de déplacement les juges
des enfants qui devraient être présents
dans les comités intercommunaux de
sécurité de prévention de délinquence ne
n'auront pas le temps et nulle création
d'emploi n'est prévu où va-t-on trouver
le temps pour les mettre l'article 41
qui prévoit une mesure systématique de
paiement des droits par la personne qui
bénéficie de l'aide juridictionnelle les
enfants en bénéficieront-ils ou les
enfants trouveront-ils les 8,80 € quand
on veut entendre leurs parole représenté
par un avocat devant un juge des enfants
dans des cas de divorce difficiles les
plus vulnérables une fois de plus seront
touchés comme beaucoup trop souvent par
ce gouvernement nous allons donc vers
une justice à deux vitesses vers une
justice qui ne sera accessible qu'au col
blanc qui ne sera accessible qu'au
caides de l'économie souterraine alors
que l'on affffiche que l'on veut lutter
contre ces caïes de l'économie
souterraine qui pourrissent
véritablement aujourd'hui la sécurité
dans notre société c'est encore la même
chose avec la réforme de la
représentation devant la cour d'appel et
les avoués c'est toujours toujours la
même chose avec l'aide juridictionnelle
donc vous vous gargarisez de
l'augmentation mais cette augmentation
globale pas vous mais le gouvernement
auquel vous appartenez monsieur le
ministre l'augmentation de l'aide
juridictionnelle servira tout juste à
absorber l'augmentation de la TVA des
honoraires des avocats et les retards
pris en la matière depuis 2 ans la carte
judiciaire soumise au gré d'ouverture de
fermeture et de réouverture si on était
allé moins vite et je parle en
connaissance de cause dans certains
territoires je ne remets pas en cause le
bien fondé des réouvertures je remet en
cause la précipitation et l'absence de
concertation qui a présidé une fois de
plus à cette réforme et qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui on répare à grand coup
des erreurs qu'on aurait pu éviter si on
était allé moins vite alors à gauche
monsieur le ministre nous ne souffrons
pas de cet espèce de dédoublement de la
personnalité qui semble affecter tous
les membres du gouvernement et de la
majorité parlementaire et bien entendu
nous ne voterons pas ce
budget merci je donne maintenant la
parole à Monsieur Michel Mercier garde
des sauts ministre de la Justice et des
Libertés
bonjour madame la
Présidente et
félicitations que j'ai droit à dépasser
tout le
temps qu'il ont
dépassé
40 ch madame le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs mieur les sénateurs messieurs
les présidents de commission monieur
rapporteur spécial messieurs les
rapporteurs VO
alors je voudrais tout d'abord remercier
l'ensemble des membres du Sénat et plus
particulièrement les rapporteurs qui
sont venus ce matin avec un temps pas
toujours facile pour arriver jusqu'au
Palais du Luxembourg pour ce budget de
la justice pour moi cel la montre bien
sûr sur l'intérêt que la Haute Assemblée
a toujours porté à la justice et
véritablement la grande connaissance de
ce ministère dont on témoignait le
rapporteur spécial et l'ensemble des
rapporteurs comme d'ailleurs les
intervenants et je voulais remercier
tous les intervenants de ce matin
j'essayerai de répondre d'ailleurs à
chacun d'entre vous puisque vous avez
tous posé des questions extrêmement
intéressantes pertinentes et j'essayerai
dans la mesure du possible de vous
apporter des réponses pour respecter le
temps que m'a accordé madame la
Présidente mais si elle fait preuve
d'autant de bienveillance à mon égard
qu'elle a bien voulu en faire preuve
vis-à-vis des membres du Sénat nous
sommes ensemble jusque vers 1h de
l'après-midi pour pouvoir répondre à
l'ensemble des questions qui ont été
posées al je voudrais tout
d'abord titre d'introduction rappeler
cela est vrai
que le budget des crédits du ministère
de la justice sont en augmentation cette
année
mais je
maisur je vous ai jamais interrompu et
si vous vouliez bien laisser terminer ma
phrase ce serait une
nouveauté not
table je vis dire pour moi le fait même
que dans le
contexte des finances publiques que nous
connaissons tous le fait qu'on augmente
les crédits et du ministère de la
justice c'est la fois la reconnaissance
qu'il y a un retard important et qu'il y
a par ailleurs une demande de la part de
nos concitoyens fortes dans ce domaine
et puis aussi que nous avons votter que
vous avez voté des réformes importantes
comme la loi pénitentiaire et dans
quelques jours la réforme de la garde à
vue entraînera encore d'autres
augmentations de ce budget et je
voudrais dire que ça permettra de
répondre à Madame clè tout de suite j'ai
bien comprise tout ce qu'elle nous a dit
c'était quelque peu excessif dans cette
expression mais je voudrais lui dire que
le retard des crédits du ministère de la
Justice il ne date pas
d'aujourd'hui et que c'est une histoire
ancienne ancienne dont nous sommes tous
responsables à un moment ou à un autre
et que il faut qu'on ait conscience de
de cela et qu'ensemble on essaie
d'apporter des réponses alors j'ai bien
vu que on pouvait faire des comparaisons
madame borveau est devenue soudainement
la plus européenne d'entre nous et moi
je suis très heureux de voir cette
évolution puisquelle a bien voulu
comparer le budget de la justice à
l'ensemble des budgets des autres États
européens je voudrais simplement dire
que si on s'en tenait à ces comparaisons
c'est vrai que nous sommes pas très bien
placé dans un classement mais beaucoup
mieux dans un autre puisque en fait
derrière l'Italie nous sommes de de deè
état pour le montant global du budget de
la justice il est vrai qu'on ne connaît
pas tous les budgets de la justice de
tous les États européens moi je voudrais
simplement vous inviter mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs à considérer que
la justice a un budget qui augmente avec
lequel on essaie de rattraper un certain
nombre de retard que nous sommes dans un
contexte financier extrêmement difficile
et que pour arriver à ce résultat
d'augmentation il faut une vraie volonté
politique en faveur de ce ministère et
c'est d'ailleurs ce qui a été fait
aujourd'hui et pour la première fois
nous allons passer à plus de 7 milliards
d'euros pour le budget de la justice et
la loi de programmation
2011-2014 prévoit une continuation de
cet effort puisque nous devrions être à
7,37 milliards d'euros à la fin de
l'application de cette loi et
c'est-à-dire en 2013 donc des moyens
conséquents sont mobilisés il faut les
renforcer et il faut aussi plusieurs
d'entre vous l'ont d'ailleurs noté
veiller à améliorer la gestion de ce
ministère les moyens conséquents
mobilisés vous les avez vu euh tous et
je ne veux pas pour reprendre une
expression de certains d'entre vous
gargariser de tel ou tel résultat
puisque d'abord ce budget il a été
préparé par Madame aonarie et je le fais
bien et je la remercie d'ailleurs
d'avoir obtenu ce qu'elle a obtenu comme
moyen supplémentaire mais que je sais
parfaitement par ailleurs vous l'avez
confirmé dans tous dans vos
interventions qu'il y a encore loin à un
état parfait des choses donc c'est
plutôt euh avec humilité que je présente
ce budget donc les moyens de juridiction
sont une des priorités de ce budget de
2011 des crédits sont ainsi déployés
pour accompagner la dernière phase de
mise en œuvre de la carte judiciaire et
de la modernisation des palais de
justice je signale d'ailleurs que quand
on regarde les crédits les moyens des
jurdiction sont à peu près les mêmes que
l'année précédente mais comme il y a
beaucoup moins de crédit pour la mise en
place de la réforme de la carte
judiciaire en fait les moyens des
juridictions augmentent sensiblement
cette année mais je voudrais insister
sur la création de 399 postes de
greffier c'est quelque chose
d'extrêmement important même si nous
devons continuer dans ce mouvement pour
arriver à un ratio de 1 pour 1 et je
voudrais rassurer monsieur suur nous
av'avons pas l'intention de diminuer le
nombre de magistrats juste pour faire en
sorte qu'il y ait autant de magistrat
que de greffier j'ai bien retrouvé la
subtilité de son esprit dans ce calcul
mathématique à l'envers pour nous
montrer que on peut tout démontrer mais
ce n'est pas ce que nous souhaitons
faire nous voulons véritablement
améliorer les moyens dont disposent les
magistrats pour assurer leur travail et
j'y reviendrai d'ailleurs en répondant à
une question de Monsieur Duluard tout à
l'heure donc ces nouveaux recrutements
sont tout à fait indispensables à
l'efficacité de l'institution judiciaire
voilà donc
euh ce premier point euh il y a
également des crédits euh relativement
importants pour poursuivre la mise en
sécurité des juridictions ce qui est une
des conditions d'un exercice serein de
la justice le plan en cours sera achevé
dès le printemps 2011 moderniser le
fonctionnement de la justice et aussi
moderniser les procédures et faciliter
l'échange d'informations et de données
entre tous les acteurs judiciaires à cet
égard les nouvelles technologies sont
une chance pour pourintitution elle
révolutionne les méthodes de travail et
constitue un vecteur d'efficacité je
reviendrai sur cassop pour répondre à
Monsieur du Luard et à Monsieur de
tregne tout à l'heure la modernité de la
justice réside donc dans la défense de
valeurs qui sont essentielles beaucoup
d'entre vous ont parlé de l'accès de
tous à la justice c'est une des valeurs
essentielle sur laquelle la modernité de
la justice doit être assise et nous
travaillons actuellement des solutions
sur l'aide juridictionnelle et son
financement les crédits progressent et
je m'en félicite pour atteindre 312
millions d'euros cette année mais je
sais aussi que ces crédits ne seront pas
suffisants notamment avec la mise en
œuvre de la garde d' vue en matière en
matière pénitentiaire pardon les moyens
sont significativement renforcé car il
est de notre devoir de veiller à la
situation des détenus mais aussi aux
conditions de travail des personnels
cette double préoccupation s traduit par
la hausse notable du budget alloué au
programme pénitentiaire les les crédits
progressent de 4,4 % pour atteindre près
de 900 millions d'euros les effectifs
sont également en hausse nous créons
563 nouveaux emplois la situation
matérielle des présons est une
préoccupation majeure eu beaucoup
d'entre vous sont intervenus sur ce
thème grâce au programme de rénovation
les établissements vêut seront fermés au
profit de nouvelles places conformes aux
règles pénitentiaires européennes la
modernisation du parc pénitentiaire doit
se poursuivre nous travaillons à
l'élaboration d'un nouveau programme le
plan mise en place en 2002 s'achevant en
2012 mais j'aurai l'occasion en
répondant aux questions de revenir sur
ce
point faire en sorte que les moyens
augmentent cela est bien mais le second
taxe d'action doit être très
naturellement celui qui consiste à
améliorer la gestion budgétaire et cela
constitue un défi majeur pour le
ministère plusieurs projets sont conduit
par mes services en vue d'une gestion
plus rationnelle des moyens nous
veillons à une politique d'achat plus
efficace des efforts sont par ailleurs
entrepris pour la maîtrise des frais et
notamment des frais justes
même si nous savons que est extrêmement
difficile la Chancellerie travaille
actuellement à de nouveaux dispositifs
pour réduire les coûts à la matière et
mieux mutualiser les moyens la
réalisation d'une plateforme nationale
des interceptions judiciaires est aussi
à
l'étude précision pour Monsieur deg elle
permettrait en particulier des économies
d'échelle mais la rationalisation des
moyens doit être conçue de façon globale
en recentrant chacun sur son son cœur de
métier au sein de l'institution
judiciaire mais plus généralement aussi
dans la sphère publique il est prévu que
les transférements des personnes sous
man justice soient assuré par les
personnels judiciaaires et non plus par
la police des négociations ont eu lieu
transfert de 800 emplois entre
l'intérieur et la justice on été assuré
des négociations sont en cours sur ce
point
pour obtenir peut-être une meilleure
notation d'une manière générale je veux
donner au personnel de justice les moyen
de leur action recentrer les personnels
sur leur mission tel est aussi
l'objectif de la restructuration en
cours de la protection judiciaire de la
jeunesse la réforme porte sur le cœur
des missions mais aussi sur
l'organisation territoriale de la
direction de la pGG nous devons
envisager toutes ces questions sur le
long terme et c'est naturellement
l'ambition que je porte et la
programmation pluriannuelle des finances
publiques nous permet d'engager
pleinement cette réflexion je sais
pouvoir compter sur les débats
parlementaires et notamment sur ceux de
la Haute Assemblée pour enrichir et
amender à la fois nos réflexions et
probablement notre vision des choses et
je voudrais maintenant si vous le voulez
bien essayer d'apporter des réponses au
question que vous nous avez posé je vous
remercie toutes et tous d'avoir posé des
questions qui sont à la fois des
questions très importantes et et souvent
des questions très précises alors celles
pour lesquelles je n'aurai pas de
réponse maintenant je m'engage d'ors
déjà à vous répondre par écrit ensuite
tout d'abord monsieur Duluard rapporteur
spécial nous pose une question qui pour
moi est essentielle et et constitue un
champ entier extrêmement important et
qu'en est-il exactement de l'effectivité
ou de l'exécution des peines pénales et
et je dois dire que quand j'ai été nommé
j'ai regardé un petit peu toutes les
questions et cette question là pour moi
j'imaginais pas quelle est cette
importance or l'inspection générale des
service en mars 2009 avait indiqué qu'il
y avait 82000 peines en attente
d'exécution cela signifie donc à
l'évidence 1 que contrairement à ce que
l'on dit parfois les magistrats ne sont
pas laxistes ils font leur métier il
faut le dire clairement et hautement par
contre il faut très naturellement que
les décisions de justice soient exécuté
d'une façon ou d'une autre il s'agit pas
créer 82000 places de prison
supplémentair d'ailleurs on y arriverait
pas c'est évident il s'agit donc
d'utiliser tout le panel de réponses que
nous offre la loi pénitencière et les
autres textes pour faire en sorte que
toutes les décisions de justice soient
exécuté pour moi dans les 18 mois à peu
près maximum que que peut compter mon
ministère mais après il y aura
probablement je l'espère une continuité
mais peut-être des remplacements donc
c'est un chantier
parce que il faut que nos
concitoyens voi que la justice fait son
travail et ça on peut pas laisser 82000
peines non exécuté déploiement
d'ailleurs de l'application Copé je
réponds par là à Monsieur deg également
dès le mois de janvier va nous permettre
d'obtenir un décte précis du nombre
d'exécution des peines et voir où on en
est moi j'ai demandé que pas dans mon
bureau parce que je suis pas très
spécialiste d'utilisation de ces
appareils mais dans le bureau du
directeur de cabinet il y ait en
permanence un tableau où on puiss suivre
le nombre d'exécutions des peines et
aussi le nombre des peines non exécutées
voilà donc monsieur le rapporteur
spécial la réponse que je peux vous
apporter je sais qu'il y a là un
chantier tout à fait
fondamental vous avez posé ensuite la
question de savoir où est-ce que l'on
était monsieur mzard a posé la même
question si vous acceptez je répondrai
aux de sénateur en même temps euh conna
est-il exactement de la reprise de
certaines missions par l'administration
pénitentiaire je vrais d'abord répondre
d'une façon générale 1 moi je souhaite
recentrer les tous les agents du
ministère de la Justice sur leur
métier il y avait dans le rapport
ginchard des choses très intéressantes
relatives au magistrat on demande dans
ce pays au magistrat de faire des tas de
choses hein beaucoup trop
alors qu'on doit les concentrer sur leur
métier et j'entends bien reprendre cette
disposition du rapport gincha dès qu'on
crée une commission dont on sait pas
bien comment elle va fonctionner comment
ça va qu'est-ce que ça va donner on dit
tiens on va mettre un magistrat à la
tête et tout de suite c'est un hommage
rendu au magistrat bien entendu puis
qu'on leur fait une grande confiance
mais il n'ont pas été forcément recrutés
pour cela donc ça c'est le premier point
général de deuxèmement le Gouvernement a
souhaité recentrer l'activité de la
police et de la gendarmerie sur leur
activité de base l'administration
pénitentiaire doit donc reprendre
certaines missions notamment les
transférement des détenus sous man
justice la la la garde des unités
hospitalières alors nous avons deux
problèmes une première négociation a eu
lieu entre la justice et l'Intérieur
çaela s'est traduit par un transfert de
800 emplois du ministère de l'intérieur
vers le ministère de la Justice ce
transfert sera peut-être insuffisant au
vu de la charge de travail nous sommes
en train d'essayer d'analyser exactement
le nombre de transferts et ce à quoi ils
correspondent nous sommes quand même
avec de vraies difficultés statistiques
on va dire ça comme cela c'est la raison
pour laquelle il va y avoir des
expérimentations dans de régions et nous
sommes toujours en discussion avec le
ministère de l'Intérieur pour choisir
ces deux régions
apparemment les deux ministères sont
assez d'accord pour choisir la Lorine
pour ce qui est de la seconde région il
y a encore des discussions mais c'est là
quelque chose d'essentiel et on peut
voir que très souvent on manque
cruellement d'indications statistiques
fiables alors je voudrais répondre
maintenant à Monsieur le cerf qui nous a
interrogé sur la mise en œuvre de la loi
pénitentiire qui s'est inquiété de d'une
déconnexion trop grande entre dans le
temps entre l'application de la loi
pénitentiaire et les moyens qui pourrai
suivre je voudrais tout d'abord rappeler
que s'agissant des conseillers
d'insertion et de probation qui sont
tout à fait essentiel dans l'application
de la loi pénitentiire ça va dire que
les choses avaient peut-être commencé un
peu auparavant entre 2002 et 2010 leur
nombre a augmenté de
3941 soit une augmentation de 143 %
aujourd'hui il y a
3941 conseillers d'association et de
probation en plus qu'en 2002 c'est donc
un progrès qui est tout à fait certain
alors est-ce que cela est suffisant je
peux noter simplement que cette
augmentation a déjà permis de faire face
au développement des aménagements de
peine mais qu'il y aura probablement à
continuer cet
effort sur euh les les programmes euh de
euh prison et de réponse pénitentière
moi je me souviens parfaitement du jour
où le Sénat a voté le principe de
l'encellulement individuel et c'est un
principe qui est inscrit dans la loi
c'est une règle de droit qui s'impose
très naturellement au gouvernement comme
à l'ensemble des citoyens de ce pays et
c'est donc une obligation pour
l'administration pénitentiaire et et il
est donc difficile de considérer que
plus de 30 % de détenus euh peuvent
renoncer à ce droit ou renonceront à ce
droit de façon automatique ce sont des
statistiques que l'on peut faire mais et
ce dont on est sûr c'est qu'au jour
d'aujourd'hui euh le ce principe même
nécessite à la fois eu et justifie le
nouveau programme de 5000 places euh tel
qu'il a été décidé par le Président de
la République et que nous allons mettre
en œuvre et que très naturellement il
nécessite aussi que nous revoyons euh
l'ensemble euh des questions d'ouverture
et de fermeture euh d'établissement euh
j'ai bien vu monsieur le sererf euh les
résultats desmissions que vous avez
conduitees euh dans certains
établissement euh vous n dites il y a
pas de vrais problème euh et puis dans
d'autres établissements bah sont des
établissements qui sont extrêmement
vétustes et et qui sont indignes donc
tous les établissements véustes et
indignes bah il faut les détruire et et
les remplacer pour les autres on va
regarder l'ensemble de la question et
j'ai bien compris que l'établissement
d'oriaque n'était pas dans la catégorie
vétuste et indigne puisque des travaux
au lieu récemment de façon importante et
j'envisage d'aller vérifier sur place à
HAC la bonne bon état de cette
IBE comme je suis déjà dans le
dépassement du temps que madame la
Présidente m'a donné je vais essayer
d'aller le plus vite possible monsieur
dereg nous a interrogé sur la gestion
provisionnelle des effectifs de
magistrats et de greffiers alors c'est
vrai qu'il faut tout à fait qu'on mette
en place cette gestion
prévisionnelle c'est pas parce que on na
pas répondu clairement sur ce point que
les créations de postees sont pas des
créations supplémentaires c'est vrai
qu'il y a qu'il y aura des départs dans
l'avenir et la détermination je peux
vous assurer des niveaux de recrutement
des magistrats est est élaboré sur la
base d'une gestion prévisionnelle et des
effectifs telle qu'elle a été mise en
place par la Direction des services
judiciaire sont également intégré les
études d'impact liées aux différentes
réformes carart judiciaire modification
des textes existant en matière
procédurale notamment concernant les
prévisions de départ à la retraite elles
sont réalisées à partir d'un taux moyen
de départ en retraite observé sur les
années précédentes je sais parfaitement
monsieur dereg que nous allons rentrer
dans le baby boom et que il y aura un
peu plus de départ que auparavant
s'agissant des recrutements il vient de
préciser que seul le niveau de
recrutement de l'année 2011 a été
déterminé dans le projet de loi de
finances 2011 les recrutement ainsi
réalisés seront effectifs pour les
juridictions en 2013 les niveaux de
recrutement postérieurs à 2011 visent à
compenser les départs en retraite
prévisionnelles et tendre ainsi VI une
stabilisation des effectifs de magistrat
s'agissant des personnels des greffes un
bureau de la gestion prévisionnelle des
ressources humaines sera créé à partir
du 1er janvier
2011 pour Monsieur de Treg toujours
s'agissant des locaux du Conseil
supérieur de la magistrature l'entrée en
vigueur de la réforme du Conseil
Supérieur va effectivement entraîner une
augmentation de membres du
conseil et nous entendons répondre
s'agissant des locaux dans un premier
temps dans le cadre du projet de
regroupement des services de
l'administration centrale sur un site
unique et bien en dehors de la place
vendô le ministère de la Justice va
disposer de locaux inoccupés et qui
pourront être affectés au Conseil
supérieur de la magistrature et nous
examinerons avec le CSM tout comme avec
la cour justice de la République la
possibilité de trouver des leco adapté à
ce nouvel effectif et puis lors de une
fois construit le nouveau TGI de Paris
il y aura probablement avec auprès de la
Cour de cassation des locaux suffisants
pour accueillir le CSM dans le palais
historique pour Monsieur
Alfonsi je voudrais dire simplement que
très rapidement que l'État ne se retire
pas de l'activité de la PGJ au contraire
euh il maintient une activité très forte
euh et que s'agissant des mineurs
délinquants et et des mineurs en danger
l'activité
euh crédit reste important puisque 64
millions d'euros sont prévus à ce titre
sur le dispositif jeune majeur le
recentrage de la PGJ sur les délinquants
a été décidé par le Parlement 2007 et
nous allons pouvoir regarder de près si
les départements ont pris la relève je
peux vous assurer que j'en connais au
moins un qui l'a fait mais il y en a
beaucoup d'autres également euh pour
madame la Présidente borveau je voudrais
lui dire que la création de 399 postes
de greffi répond à une demande des
organisations syndicales de magistrat et
de greffi vous nous avez dit bien sûr
que le budget était insuffisant moi je
vous remercie de votre soutien sur ce
point mais je sais que dans les
circonstances qui sont extrêmement
difficiles augmenter de 4,4 % un budget
ça montre une priorité une volonté de
rattrapage et que là encore euh le
gouvernement fait preuve de
responsabilité sur les PPP vous avez
expliqué en fait votre de principe sur
les PPP moi je veux simplement rappeler
que historiquement notre pays s'est
construit largement en associant le
public et le privé toutes les liges de
chemin de fer par exemple ont été
construites grâce au système de la
concession aujourd'hui nous utilisons
partenariat public privé c'est je je
crois ce qui nous permet de répondre
rapidement à une demande forte nous le
faisons sans préavis idéologique et je
veux signaler que chaque PPP fait
l'objet d'une évaluation économique et
cela est le cas pour quand Perpignan et
Lille cette année et ce n'est pas
d'ailleurs un choix systématique le
ministère conserve un budget important
dans le domaine immobilier s'agissant du
manque que pardon euh des inter de
l'intervention de Monsieur betteille et
je le remercie des soit qu' a bien voulu
formuler à mon égard je voudrais lui
indiquer que s'agissant des crédits de
fonctionnement des
juridictions ces crédits vont ils sont
stables facialement qu'il y a moins de
crédit pour euh la mise en œuvre de la
réforme de la carte judiciaire ils
seront simplement ces crédits de 4
millions en 2000 compte 18,9 millions en
2010 et donc globalement les crédits
pour les instit pour les juridictions
augmenteront de
11,7 millions d'euros s'agissant des
structures de prise en charge
psychiatrique des personnes détenues je
fais bien vos observations je veux
simplement signaler que la santé mentale
des personnes détenu relève depuis
1994 du ministère de la Santé et ne
relève plus du ministère de la Justice
chaque région pénitentiaire dispose de
services médicau-psychologiques
régionaux et pour épauler ces structures
la loi d'orientation et de programmation
pour la justice a acté la mise en place
d'unités hospitalière spécialement
aménagé
uhs1 et j'ai d'ailleurs eu l'honneur de
participer à l'inauguration de celle de
Lyon vintier le 21 mai dernier c'était
la première en France et le programme de
construction porte sur 705 lit la
première tranche d'une capacité de 440
places sera réalisée de 2010 à
2012 s'agissant du recouvrement de l'IG
juridictionnel vous avez plutôt raison
sur ce que vous nous avez dit le projet
de loi de finance améliore le
recouvrement de l'aide juridictionnel
indumement perçu lorsque les
justiciables reviennent à meilleure
fortune et l'article 41 du projet de
boie de finance pour 2011 que le Sénat a
adopté la semaine dernière permettra
simplifier la procédure donc de la
rendre plus efficace chisissant de
l'intervention de monsieur Sueur je lui
ai déjà répondu sur les questions de
classement cela est tout à fait vrai
que je vais le plus vite possible madame
la Présidente je générosité monsieur
mais je veux répondre à tout le monde
mais je je fais appel à votre
bienveillance sinon il y aura des des je
naurais pas pu répondre à tout le monde
je veux dire à monsieur Sueur que le
ratio greffier magistrat augmente et
c'est bien je veux lui dire que sur
l'affaire
d'Orléan pour ma part j'ai confié une
mission à l'inspection générale des
services je n'ai pas pour habitude de
parler avant d'avoir un dossier solide
j'attends le rapport de l'Inspection
générale et des services je rappelle
qu'il y avait déjà eu l'an dernier une
inspection sur le fonctionnement du TGI
d'Orléan qui n'avait d'ailleurs pas
conclu un déficit de moyens en terme
d'effectif mais à la nécessité de
réorganiser certains services notamment
ce traitant le pénal c'est d'ailleurs ce
que sont en train de faire les chefs de
cours et de juridiction avec l'aide de
la Chancellerie sur le rapport sur la
base du rapport de l'Inspection générale
des service donc nous attendrons et nous
travaillerons dans ce cadre-là pour
monsieur mard il a dit beaucoup de
choses
oui oui j'ai
oui mais je vous répondrai probablement
si vous me laissez
parler voilà pour conclure ah vous
voulez je vous répondre à vous et ben je
vous répondrai sans problème je vous
répondrai que comme vous nous avez
indiqué et que notamment l'arrêt de la
Cour européenne des droits de l'homme
posé certain nombre de problèmes il vous
a pas manqué en ayant lu cet arrêt
jusqu'au bout et en l'ayant analysé au
fond que c'est un arrêt qui conduit tout
droit à la suppression des juges
d'instruction parce que ne plus vouloir
que les mag que oui mais faut ah je
pense monsieur Jung qu'il faut qu'il
faut lire les décisions complètement et
pas simplement et pas simplement ce qui
peut en être écrit de deux liges moi
j'ai appris il y a bien longtemps à lire
les arrêts de la Cour européenne des
droits de l'homme et ayant participé au
commentaires de quelques-uns je peux
donc vous dire que j'ai lu celui-ci dans
sa totalité et que à ne plus vouloir
conserver le parquet à la française et
en faire simplement une partie devant un
juge autre et bien cela bien sûr
transforme complètement la procédure
pénale nous entraîne à une procédure
accusatoire et fait qu'il y a plus
besoin de juge d'instruction mais tout
autrement alors Mo pour l'instant nous
analysons l'ensemble de ces décisions
nous avons à réformer la garde à vue
nous avons chantier des décisions
pénales non exécuté et nous avons la
question des jurés populaires dans
l'ensemble des
juridictions pour ce qui est de ce début
de l'année ce sera probablement
suffisant sagit ant de Monsieur
mard qui nous a parlé de la
désertification comprend parfaitement ce
thème je veux lui dire que il aucun
territoire ne sera abandonné et que nous
aurons d'ailleurs à retrouver cette
question dans la loi sur la garde à vue
parce qu'on peut avoir un texte qui
marche bien à Paris et dans les grandes
villes et qui marchera pas beaucoup dans
les territoires alors si vous voulez
bien on réabordera parce que madame la
Présidente me dit que j'ai largement
dépassé à la pasur réabordera cette
question à cette occasion euh pour
Monsieur Jung je voudrais simplement lui
dire que sur Draguignan j'ai bien
compris son message que nous avons eu un
sinistre je veux signaler le grand
professionnalisme des équipes de
l'administration pénitentière qui ont
évité et le pire et que nous allons
reconstruire à liignant sur un autre
site non inondable et que les élus euh
nous avons des discussions avec les élus
pour trouver et ce site
actuellement pour répondre à Madame clè
je le bracelet électronique nous avons
déjà 5000 personnes placées sous
bracelet électronique il n'y a pas eu
d'incident grave à ce jour mais pour
l'instant nous en sommes là alors
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs je
n'ai pas répondu la totalité de vos
questions celles et ceux auquel je n'ai
pas pu répondre je le ferai par écrit
dans les jours qui viennent je vous
remercie de votre écoute après avoir
remercié madame la Présidente de son
immense bonté merci merci monsieur le
ministre nous allons procéder à l'examen
des amendements portant sur les crédits
de la mission justice figurant à l'état
B donc à l'article 48 l'amendement
87 que présente monsieur desregne
merci madame la
présidente monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues cet amendement a pour
objet d'ériger les crédits du Conseil
supérieur de la magistrature en un
programme spécifique au sein de la euh
euh au sein de de la mission justice
judiciaire pourquoi parce que depuis la
mise en œuvre de
l'alolf la commission des lois réclame
chaque année que soit créée une mission
spécifique une pour
le pour le Conseil supérieur de la
magistrature sans succès aucun d'année
en année le les crédits du Conseil
supérieur de la magistrature sont
toujours inclus au sein des crédits de
la justice judiciaire au niveau du
Parlement nous avons la possibilité de
créer au sein
de de la mission nous avons la
possibilité de créer un programme
Conseil supérieur de la magistrature
c'est donc l'objet de cet amendement
c'est très simple ça ne priverai pas les
autres secteurs du domaine judiciaire du
moindre crédit puisque nous prélevons en
recette et en dépense les crédits qui
sont de
2929394 € aussi bien en autorisation
d'engagement qu'en crédit de paiement
dans le domaine justice judiciaire pour
les mettre dans un nouveau programme
Conseil supérieur de la magistrature
c'est la première raison la deuxième
raison c'est que la réforme
constitutionnelle de 2008 et la loi
organique de juillet et 2010 qui a été
prise à la suite de cette réforme
spécifie clairement je cite que
l'autonomie budgétaire du Conseil
supérieur est assuré dans les conditions
déterminées par une loi de finance nous
sommes en loi de finance c'est le moment
ou jamais de régler cette question et
d'ériger effectivement l'autonomie du
conseil de la supérieur de la
magistrature à l'intérieur d'un
programme spécifique à défaut de créer
une mission
spécifique enfin euh je voudrais
signaler qu'il y a un petit problème de
fond pour le Conseil supérieur de la
magistrature à être dans le programme
justice judiciaire pourquoi parce que le
responsable du programme justice
judiciaire c'est le directeur des
services judiciaires personne tout à
fait estimable hein là n'est pas la
question mais le directeur des services
judiciaires c'est en même temps celui
qui transmet la plupart des nomination
des propositions de nomination sur
lesquelles le Conseil supérieur de la
magistrature a à se prononcer par
ailleurs imaginez je prends un exemple
comme ça que le Conseil supérieur de la
magistrature décide d'envoyer une
mission dans un territoire d'outrem un
peu éloigné de la métropole pour
examiner le fonctionnement de tel ou tel
juridiction ou dans le cadre d'une
enquête sur un problème qui a été
soulevé porté auprès du Conseil
supérieur de la magistrature et qu'ils
doivent demander des crédits au
directeurs des services judiciaires vous
conviendrez qu'il y a un vrai problème
de principe qui est là posé alors à
défaut de pouvoir faire une par exemple
mettre les crédits du Conseil supérieur
de la magistrature dans la mission
pouvoir public comme le sont les crédits
du Conseil constitutionnel ou les
crédits de la Cour de Justice de la
République ce que nous demandions depuis
des années et bien la commission des
lois à l'unanimité de ses membres
propose que nous instaurions un
programme spécifique un programme
Conseil supérieur de la
magistrature à l'intérieur de la mission
justice judiciaire merci quel du
gouvernement monsieur le
ministre la commission pardon
d'abord oui monsieur le rapporteur de la
commission des
lois voilà l'avis de la commission des
Finances depuis l'entrée pardon en
application de la LOLF les crédits du
CSM sont portés par l'action 4 du
programme justice judiciaire de la
mission justice cette action était en
effet exclusivement consacrée au CSM à
cet égard il convient de souligner que
le présent projet de loi de finance
prévoit qu'en 2011 les crédits du CSM
vont augmenter de 31 % passant de 2,23 à
2 2,20 92 millions d'euros cette hausse
conséquente des moyens de CSM vise à lui
permettre de mettre en œuvre dans de
bonnne conditions la réforme dont il a
fait l'objet à l'occasion de la loi de
juillet 2010 la Commission des finances
du Sénat est tout à fait soucieuse de
l'autonomie du CSM garant du bon
fonctionnement de l'institution et à ce
titre elle comprend parfaitement euh la
philosophie ayant guidé la commission
des lois dans le dépôt de cet amendement
par ailleurs dans sa lettre la LOLF
n'impose aucun plafond ni aucun plancher
s'agissant du montant des crédits d'un
programme pour autant la commission des
Finances estime également nécessaire de
s'assurer du caractère opérationnel
disposition budgétairees proposé or de
ce point de vue un programme d'une
surface financière aussi limité que
celui que propose le présent amendement
poserait de réelles difficultés en
gestion le principe de la fongibilité
des crédits ne pouvant guère s'appliquer
en tant que de besoin au cours de
l'exercice la sanctuarisation des
crédits du SSM pourrait donc avoir un
effet paradoxal de fragiliser
budgétairement le conseil ici en quelque
sorte la D selon lequelle le mieux et
l'ennemi du bien trouverait une
regrettable application concrète pour
tout à fait complet il faut d'ailleurs
rappeler qu'actuellement dans le casre
de la LOLF aucun programme ne s'appuie
sur une aussi faible surface de crédit
peut-être faudrait-il en liaison avec le
gouvernement prévoir que pour 2011 le
CSM fasse partie de la mission pouvoir
public et à ce moment-là les choses
seraient beaucoup plus claires voilà
donc la commission des finances en
l'état donne un avis défavorable ou une
demande de retrait monsieur le ministre
monsieur le pardon monsieur le président
de la commission des finances oui pour
pour que le ministre veille bien
répondre à à notre souhait je pense que
nos collègues de la commission des lois
sont allés jusqu'au bout de ce que le
Parlement peut faire dans une loi de
finance mais la réponse n'est pas
vraiment satisfaisante la la seule bonne
réponse c'est l'inclusion dans la
mission pouvoir public du CSM à ce
moment-là il y aura une dotation et il y
aura parfaite
conformité mission et indépendance donc
peut-être pourrions-nous monsieur le
garde des saous d'ici la prochaine loi
de finance convenir d'un dispositif qui
permettrait d'inclure le CSM dans la
mission pouvoir
public monsieur le
ministre merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs sénateurs monsieur
de TRG et puis monsieurs les présidents
de la commission des lois et de la
commission des finances moi je comprends
bien ce que vous souhaitez faire le
Conseil constitutionnel a d'ailleurs
donné une indication dans ce sens mais
je voudrais faire bien quand même les
arguments de Monsieur Duluard pour dire
que la face financière du CSM est très
faible fonctionnement c'est 800000 € par
an à partir de là offert une une
sanctuirisation peut nous amener au
blocage du CSM par exemple la nécessité
de faire un déplacement pour des
enquêtes disciplinaires ou tromire bien
c'est terminé il y aura on va paralyser
le CSM alors ce que ce que je voudrais
dire à Monsieur degne c'est que je
comprends ce qui a voulu dire et ce
qu'ont voulu dire les présidents des
deux commissions sur ce point je propose
monsieur de de retirer votre amendement
et et de nous permettre de travailler
avec la commission des finances avec la
commission des lois pour qu'on règle ce
problème dans l'année qui
vient et je vous propose je vous demande
de bien voir retirer l'amendement sinon
je Seris obligé d'émettre un avis
défavorable madame la Présidente bvoau
merci madame la Présidente le problème
monsieur le Gard saau c'est que au
moment de où nous avons voté la loi
organique sur le CSM c'est que nous
avions exactement le même discours et
que nous avions demandé justement que à
l'occasion de la loi de finances 2011
c'est-à-dire celle-ci il puisse le CSM
puisse
être intégré à la mission pouvoir
public le gouvernement qui était présent
au moment de la discussion de la loi
organique bien entendu savait très bien
que la question se posait et
euh visiblement volontairement ou non
peut-être les changements de ministres y
ont contribué mais en tout cas ça n'a
pas été fait c'est-à-dire que nous en
sommes exactement au même point que au
moment nous avons discuté de la loi
organique où on aurait pu d'ailleurs il
y a je crois qu'on avait des amendements
sur ce point on avait on aurait pu
consacrer justement l'indépendance du
budget de du CSM et où le gouvernement
de l'époque nous a le ministre la
ministre de l'époque nous a répondu que
c'est ça n'était pas le l'objet d'une
loi organique ça ça se discute toujours
mais qu'il fallait renvoyer à la future
loi de finances c'est-à-dire celle dont
nous discutons aujourd'hui donc nous
sommes quand même très méfiants
puisque une chose qui aurait dû être
réglé avec cette loi de finance va être
renvoyée maintenant à la prochaine loi
de finance où on aura peut-être encore
le même type de réponse donc parce que
on dira que c'est un petit budget et
cetera donc je crois qu'il y a vraiment
un problème et que évidemment la
solution que propose notre rapporteur et
que nous avons soutenu enc commission
des lois n'est pas idéale mais enfin
elle manifeste clairement que nous
voulons sortir de le CSM de
euh la direction de la justice et
monsieur le ministre vous avez demandé
la
parole merci madame la Présidente moi je
suis prêt et je le redis le plus
clairement possible à étudier pour
l'année prochaine le fait qu'on mette le
CSM dans la mission pouvoir public mais
faut laisser un peu de temps pour
regarder les choses c'est la raison pour
laquelle moi je demande au rapporteur de
retirer son amendement et on peut pas
honnêtement moi j'ai pas capacité à
décider
maintenant merci Monsieur
Jung merci Madame la la
Présidente je je crois que nous sommes
dans un un bon débat et au fond le fait
qu'il y a eu un une position
unanime de la commission des lois montre
que on va dans la bonne direction nous
nous sommes toujours méfiants devant les
procrastrination
législatives on s'engage dans dans le
débat et puis évidemment un an après
tout le monde tout le monde a oublié sur
le fond les choses sont claires il
s'agit de montrer il y a pas de valeur
plus élevée il s'agit de montrer
indépendance du CSM c'est-à-dire du
judiciaire par rapport à l'exécutif
c'est ça dont nous discutons et
l'argument que c'est un budget qui
aujourd'hui fait partie de de la
politique judiciaire je crois est un bon
est un bon argument on peut pas être des
deux côtés à la fois l'argument selon
lequel c'est une petite somme je le
comprends dans la maquette mais par
rapport aux valeurs dont nous parlons
c'est un argument qui est faible donc
nous nous sommes favorables à ce que le
budget du CSM soit clairement identifié
soit autonome si vous voulez le mettre
avec les pouvoirs publics avec le
Conseil constitutionnel l'an prochain
pourquoi pas mais dans l'état actuel des
choses nous nous soutenons l'excellent
amendement de notre excellent collègue
Monsieur desrag Merci monsieur le
Président yest
oui madame président monsieur le
ministre je rappelle quand même que nous
ne faisons qu'appliquer la loi organique
du 22 juillet 2010 qui prévoit que
l'autonomie budgétaire du Conseil est
assurée des conditions déterminées par
une loi de finance mais c'est pas dans
des conditions par contre le principe
c'est l'autonomie budgétaire et oui
parce que vous comprenez on peut pas
dire deux choses contradictoires ah non
l'autonomie budgétaire alors Monsieur le
Ministre la loi est du 22 juillet les
questions d'organisation et cetera le le
la somme du enfin le montant des crédits
du du CSM n'est pas en cause c'est pas
parce que c'est une petite un petit non
parce que autrement la Cour de justice
il faudrait la mettre aussi sous la
coupe de des services judiciaires alors
je rappelle en plus que maintenant c'est
plus présidé par le Président de la
République c'est le premier président de
la Cour de cassation et cetera il y a
une volonté quand même du Parlement de
donner une autonomie réellefin du
président de la République du
constituant et du et et du gouvernement
donner une autonomie réelle au supérieur
de la magistrature donc monsieur le
ministre notre solution n'est pas bonne
forcément
puisque mais constitutionnellement nous
ne pouvons pas créer une nouvelle
mission ou ou ou transférer un programme
d'une mission à l'autre il est évident
que ça devrait être dans la mission
pouvoir public alors on vous donne
monsieur le ministre vous venez
d'arriver la loi est du 22 juillet vous
êtes en surcis
voilà voilà mais l'année prochaine on
comprend bien parce que c'est le le
budget bâti comme ça c'est très
difficile mais c'est un surcis
sans nouveau nouvell possibilités
n'est-ce pas c'est l'application stricte
de la loi dans ces conditions la
Commission des des lois qui avait voulu
signaler parce qu'on le fait déjà depuis
plusieurs années qu'il fallait changer
les choses on vous donne crédit pour
cette fois-ci monsieur le garde des saau
mais il faudra pas y revenir parce
qu'autrement ah non vraiment et surtout
que vous êtes engagé à Ess
intégrer dans la mission pouvoir public
ce qui me paraîtrait quand même
l'endroit dans le budget où doit être le
budget du Conseil supérieur de la
magistrature merci alors Monsieur
monsieur dtregne vous retirez votre
amendement merci alors l'amendement 217
du gouvernement monsieur le
ministre
l'avis de la commission oui c'est vrai
que c'est un amendement purement
technique la commission des finances est
favorableorable bien je mets au voit
cette cet amendement ceux qui sont
favorables à son adoption pouront bien
lever la
main ceux qui sont
contre abstention il est adopté
l'amendement 6 monsieur Duluard au nom
de la commission des
finances
cet amendement n'est pas une nouveauté
et on doit d'ailleurs le regretter déjà
l'an dernier lors de l'examen du projet
de loi de finance pour 2010 la
Commission des Finances avait alerté la
Chancellerie sur le dérapage des frais
de justice j'avais même comme l'a
souligné monsieur suer utilisé un terme
fort puisque j'avais parlé à l'époque
d'incincérité budgétaire pour qualifier
l'enveloppe dédiée à ce poste de dépense
pour 2010 la suite des événements nous a
malheureusement donné raison quelle est
donc la
situation alors que des progrès
substantiels ont été réalisés depuis
2006 et l'entrée en vigueur de laolf
l'année 2009 a été celle du redémarrage
des frais de justice avec un dépassement
de 23,5 million d'euros par rapport à
l'autorisation accordée en loi de
finance initiale en 2010 cette tendance
s'est confirmé le montant total de la
dépense devrait avoisiner 440 millions
d'euros pour une enveloppe initiale de
393 le montant des charges restant à
payer en fin d'année devrait qu à lui
s'élever à près de 100 millions d'euros
soit 2 mois d'activité la loi de finance
pour 2011 prévoit 459 millions d'euros
pour couvrir la dépense lié au frais de
justice il a seendant tout lieu de
penser que la sousbudgétisation observée
au cours des deux dernières années euh
reste de mise outre elle qu'elle remet à
nouveau en cause le principe de
sincérité budgétaire pour 2011 cette
situation fait courir le risque de voir
l'activité des juridictions perturbées
par le non paiement en temps et en heure
des
experts l'amendement proposé vise
d'abonder de 30 millions d'euros en
autorisation d'engagement et en crédit
de paiement l'action numéro 2 conduite
de la politique pénale et jugement des
affaires pénales du programme justice
judiciaire cet amendement est gâché sur
les autres programmes de la mission
monsieur le gardessau je connais vos
préventions à l'égard de cet amendement
je sais combien le bouclage du budget de
chacun des programmes de la mission a
été difficile dans un contexte
budgétaire tendu et je suis conscient de
l'hypothèque que ferait peser le gage de
cet amendement sur les programmes s'il
était adopté mais la situation actuelle
des frais de justice est trop critique
pour qu'elle soit pas traité à bras le
cor voyez donc dans cet amendement
monsieur le ministre l'opportunité de
nous exposer votre stratégie pour
parvenir à une meilleure maîtrise de
cette dépense en 2011 et que je ne sois
plus jamais dans la situation de vous
qualifier d'insincère monsieur le
ministre l'avis du
Gouvernement merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur
Jard je voudrais être le plus sincère
possible avec
vous et je pense que la question des
frais de justice une question lourde
pour ce
ministère pendant longtemps on a on a vu
augmenter les frais de justice avec une
grande vitesse et s d'ailleurs avoir une
possibilité quelconque
de réguler en quelque sorte ces sommes
alors que que vous apportez en réponse
d'abord la prévision pour 2010 au titre
des frais de justice et en eff fait en
dépassement par rapport à la dotation de
la loi de finance initiale 393 millions
d'euros avaient été prévu on va
probablement payer 440 millions d'euros
et cette différence sera couverte grâce
à des des redéploiements et au crédit
ouverts par le décret d'avance du 29
septembre dernier mais on peut peut-être
considérer l'année 2010 comme atypique
des services centralisateurs ont été mis
en place dans les tribunaux pour
accélérer le délai de paiement des
mémoires et ceci explique une bonne
consommation des frais de justice les
juridictions ont vidé en quelque sorte
leurs armoires et payé des mémoires
ancien le reppport de charge va être de
ce fait euh en 2011 ramené de 112
millions d'euros à 95 millions d'euros
et avec un délai de 2 mois pour le
paiement l'année prochaine les frais de
justice devraient retrouver leur rythme
tendantiel autour de 415 millions
d'euros avec un délai moyen de paiement
revenu à 2 mois ce qui est normal par
ailleurs la direction des services
judiciaires s'est lancée dans une
politique de maîtrise des frais de
justice qui doit commencer à porter ses
fruits grâce notamment à la passation de
nouveaux marchés en matière d' analyse
génétique à la diminution des tarifs
d'interception téléphonique et internet
des opérateurs à la mise en place d'un
accord type pour réduire le coût
d'enlèvement et de gardienage des
véhicules à la tarification d'un certain
nombre d'interventions notamment des
actes des médecins et des psychiatres il
reste probablement certain nombre de
professions à
tarifer pas trop je pense notamment aux
experts comptables par
exemple don le poids est
dans les frais de justice je le précise
à la demande expresse de Monsieur duuir
il faut bien dans dans ces condition la
dotation des frais de justice en 2011 à
hauteur de 459 millions d'euros dont 30
millions au titre des cotisations
sociales des collaborateurs occasionnels
du service public et 30 millions au
titre de la réforme de la médecine
légale apparaît assez bien calibré on va
essayer de pas être trop définitif en
toute état de cause un prélèvement sur
les autres programmes mettrait le
fonctionnement des services en
difficulté alors Monsieur duloir sous
sous le bénéfice des précisions que je
viens de vous apporter des efforts que
fait tant le ministère que les
juridictions pour mieux gérer ces frais
justice je vous demande de bien vouloir
renoncer à votre amendement merci
Monsieur
Duluard merci madame la Présidente oui
monsieur le gardessau je vous remercie
de l'éclairage que vous avez bien voulu
nous apporter je constate d'ailleurs
avec satisfaction une réelle convergence
de vue entre la commission des finances
et la chancellererie quant au
diagnostic depuis l'entrée de la LOLF en
vigueur de la LOLF ni la chancignerie ni
les magistrats n'ont ménagé leurs
efforts pour parvenir à contenir la
dépense des frais de justice la
commission des finances d'ailleurs l'a
souligné à plusieurs reprises toutefois
le rebond de cette dépense appelle de
nouvelles solutions toujours dans le
respect du principe d'indépendance des
magistrats à cet égard il me semble
qu'un des leviers les plus prometteurs
de cette action réside désormais dans
les services administratifs régionaux
les sars placés auprès de chaque cour
d'appel ceux-ci doivent être mis en
capacité d'éclairer d'une manière
toujours plus professionnelle la
décision du magistrat prescripteur d'une
expertise cette aide à la décision
représente assurément un un enjeu majeur
pour l'institution judiciaire dans les
mois et années à venir elle recè des
sources d'économie potentielle
importantes le juge ne doit pas être
laissé seul face à la décision il doit
plus être en quelque sorte abandonné il
doit au contraire pouvoir s'appuyer sur
un travail d'équipe avec les greffiers
avec les sars il doit pouvoir compter
sur des outils de gestion adapté et
débouchant sur une analyse aussi fine
que possible des répercussions de sa
décision
aussi je vais donc retirer mon
amendement qui est essentiellement un
remendement d'appel je vous remercie des
éclairages que vous n avez donné mais
j'insiste sur la nécessité de donner à
la formation des personnel des SARD tout
ce qu'il faut
pour pour relever le défi d'une
meilleure maîtrise des frais de justice
merci l'amendement est donc retiré
l'amendement
175 monsieur
you merci Madame la la présidente le
présent amendement tend à rendre gratuit
l'accès à la télévision dans les
établissements
pénitentiaires il concrétise il reprend
un dispositif qui avait été conçu en
1985 par notre collègue Robert baninter
lorsqu'il était garde des sauts cette
mise à disposition des téléviseurs dans
les prisons était prévu pour la Coupe du
monde de football de
1986 mais les crédits affectés ayant été
intégralement utilisés pour les travaux
de raccordement
des établissements pénitentiaires il a
été instauré par la suite un système de
location des téléviseurs qui à l'origine
ne devait être que transitoire des
associations socio-culturelles et
sportives qui gèent les 2/ers du parc
des téléviseur mettent ses postes de
télévision à la disposition des détenus
sans ressources mais les autres doivent
payer entre 5 et 40
€. de nombreux détenus voient leur
pouvoir d'achat diminuer et le poids du
poste location de téléviseur est
évidemment d'autant plus important dans
leur budget et en fait dans le système
actuel il serait plus avantageux pour un
détenu d'acheter son poste de télévision
plutôt que de louer votre prédécesseur
monsieur le ministre a proposé de fixer
un tarif unique uniforme harmonisé et
raisonnable qui s'élèverait à 8 € par
poste de télévision ce serait
semble-t-il le prix coûtant mais cet
argument ne me convainc guerre car il
laisse en suspend la question des
financements des abonnements à Canal
plus c'est ici cette initiative est
également insuffisante car elle ne tient
pas compte de la situation particulière
dans laquelle se trouvent les personnes
détenues voilà donc pour le budget de la
justice suite du projet de loi de
finances pour 2011 cet après-midi 16h30
avec le budget de l'immigration et bien
sûr toujours notre site
publsenat.fr très bonne journée sur
notre chaîne
il n'est pas candidat mais il entretient
mal